Hello, everybody.
Hello, hello.
Welcome, everybody.
We today, we are going to finish Resident Evil 4 because I
know it's not that long.
Okay, it's like five hours, I think, like around five hours.
So this is going to be a while.
We're going to be here for a while.
But also, how do I know this?
Because sometimes when I'm like hesitant and be like, the
chat tell me the right that I do.
that I'm like almost done I was thinking like was chat right
when I asked them how much I have left of the game so
sometimes if I don't want to risk it and I would like look
up I don't spoil myself I just find the exact part where I
stop at so I'll look I'll be like Resident Evil 4 uh play
through no commentary and then I try and find the area where
I stop and I can't believe I got gaslit so fucking hard in
that Ashley level.
Remember that level where you guys were like, Oh my god,
Doki, how dare you skip that part because somebody told you
the answer for the clock?
That was like one minute.
One minute.
Because the piece of paper where I find the time of like how
much I had to like of the time of the clock was literally
right next to me.
minute that I missed.
And then people in that chat were like, wow, Doki, how
fucking could you eliminating that content from us?
How could you, Doki?
I can't believe it.
Wow.
It was one minute of content.
I can't believe all of you yelled at me for one minute of
content.
I thought I missed out on something very important.
Like, I was like, oh my god, did I actually skip, like, 30
minutes of the Ashley level?
It was one minute.
It was fucking one minute.
The paper was right next to me.
Oh my god, we missed one minute of Doki being scared.
How could you, Doki?
How could you do this to us?
It was one fucking minute.
I was like, wow, let me see how much I actually missed out
on by doing the clock like right away instead of trying to
find the clue.
I can't fucking believe you guys.
Minnie, she's on to us.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I can't believe it.
The dragon finish it, Doki.
I've never seen the island.
Either way, good luck on today's run.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Lift, Toki, you don't understand.
Also, did you guys hear about the ALGS stuff?
I was watching it live on NiceWick's stream.
Because I was curious.
And then I...
And I was like...
And then like I tabbed out and I was like looking at my
Twitter.
And then people were like talking about it.
So for those who don't follow Apex Legends esports scene,
got hacked live during the tournament during and this is not
just like a regular it was like basically the the the finals
to land so like whoever does really well in this in the
finals for apex goes to land so like this was like real shit
so it was the okay i'm sorry i know it's so fucked up but it
was so funny because like so the two players were gen burden
and imperial hell um and it was so funny because when it
happened to gen burden he was like i'm getting hacked i'm
getting hacked and then he left the game instantly and then
and then when it happened to hell how was like oh my god i'm
getting hacked But what if I just stop shooting?
Because he's like, but what if I just don't shoot guys?
What if I just don't shoot?
I'm cheating, I'm cheating.
And then, and then they're like, and then he proceeds to
kill people with AIMBot.
It was so fucking funny.
He's like, he just started, proceeds to keep playing and
also continues to kill people with AIMBot.
then they were like and then like other pro players were
like why the fuck did you not leave and then the hat was
like i don't know he was like no that would be what i had
was my aim assist like i know i did that and then people
were like people were like it's so fucked up when you can't
tell if it's aim assist or if it was aim bot like no one
knows because no one knows if he used aim bot or if it was
aim assist because we can't tell it was then we can't tell
they were like it was like 1v1 and they were like up close
so no one knows which which one it was so like people can't
tell if it was off or not and um so that happened during the
apex tournament and the scary thing is that No one knows how
this person did it Is apparently like a security breach But
the thing is I think like what people like like okay So like
this hacker A lot of like the normies are like really scared
They're like oh don't turn on Don't play apex right now
don't do it Don't play apex uninstall apex Don't even touch
it because there's a security breach But like the thing is
Only this hacker has that Has that power This is only like
it's a very well This hacker has been around in the Apex
community for a while.
He always does these crazy hacks.
He always does these crazy hacks on pro players.
But this is the first time he has done this in the
tournament.
Because he's hacked Hal.
And he has hacked Hal.
And he has hacked Mandate before in the past.
This is the same hacker.
So people don't know yet.
So a lot of people are scared.
Because they're like, oh, what if it's my turn next?
Um, yeah, he's just there.
He's doing it for publicity, basically.
Like, he's just some kid that's doing this for publicity.
Some very fucking smart kid.
Uh-huh.
So I feel like right now, I know it's like, if you want to
be safe, don't touch Apex.
But most likely, like, since he's, like, the only kid that
has, like, this power.
Um, like, the, like, the people out there that are not,
like, public figures, they're okay.
Like, they're okay.
Like, the non-public figures are okay right now.
Because he's just targeting.
He's done this before.
He's breached the apex, like, security multiple times
before.
But this has been, like, the biggest publicity stunt he has
ever done.
You know when, like, okay, so those who have seen the clip
of, like, the Jen burning clip, when he, like, brought up a,
when he brought up the aimbot, because, like, he brings up
the aimbot.
If you look so closely, if you look closely at the...
The aimbot like app that he had open.
It is.
It's it's it's it's a fucking meme.
It's not even a real like aimbot app.
Like the the stuff in that in the dialogue.
If there's a screenshot.
Yeah.
There's a screenshot of it.
And it's not even the real.
It's not even like an actual app.
This kid made a fucking PNG.
Like he made like a.
fucking he made his own app he made his own fucking app like
a fake client just to troll people on like oh my god you
know this is a 15 year old kid you fucking know this is a 15
year old kid though
very smart one um but yeah it was it's actually it's
actually crazy uh it's actually insane that this happened at
best if you really do want to be safe i guess just don't
play apex at the moment if you're actually like super
paranoid but i think like for it like at like there's no
like i feel like they're just he's just targeting like
public figures at the moment to make a statement regarding
the security of EA servers because like he's done this
before and the thing is he's been the only hacker that's
been doing this other than Tuffy but for him it was Tuffy
and then Tuffy got sued to oblivion and now that's why he's
gone the reason why Tuffy's not here anymore is because he
actually got sued so like now he's gone on so now it's this
fucking 15 year old kid that's doing all of this now like
he's like he's like the successor of tuffy so um um so
that's and they always do it for publicity like like the
thing is uh it i'm not worried because like i'm not worried
or scared because like these people only Like, if they
really want to, like, fuck people over, they would not have,
like, told people that they were hacking.
They would just, actually, just, like, just, like, not even
tell anybody that, like, like, like, like, like, like, they
would throw Jen Burden under the bus and make people believe
that he was actually hacking.
But he did all of this for a publicity stunt.
That's why I'm not, like, I'm not, like, worried about it or
anything.
And, like, people are still, like, you know, like, if the
pros are still playing Apex, then they know some, I know
some.
stuff too then they then they uh then they know something we
don't because if the pros are still playing apex rank and
like they're still playing apex then they know something
that we don't or so so that's why i like i'm not like really
worried um but stop thank you for the super chat thank you
Thank you.
15-year-old versus indie developer, EA.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Also, like, yeah, so there's like, we have the Challenger
circuit.
I don't know what's going to go on with that for now.
I don't know what's happening with that.
So, like, it might be delayed.
I don't know.
Because, like, right now, all tournaments are at, like, the
pro league is postponed at the moment.
So it might affect Challenger circuit.
We don't know.
I'm waiting for, like, an announcement about what's going on
and stuff.
So, at the moment, we're just waiting.
It could be delayed, the Challenger Circuit at that point.
It could be delayed.
Anyway, what else?
Oh, yes!
And also, Razor sent me some stuff.
I actually received it recently.
I'm so happy.
I finally have a full keyboard.
Like, when they asked me, they were like, oh, hey, Doki, do
you want a 60% because you know I'm known to use 60%
keyboards or like 65% keyboards and I was like no I would
like a full keyboard because because they're like what size
keyboard do you want I was like um like dude like do you
want 60% or a full I was like a full keyboard because I have
zero full keyboards by the way all my keyboards are like cut
in some way they're like um they're like minute not
miniature what's the word they're like um they cut out some
keys that I don't normally use for like space-wise so I was
like no I would like a full keyboard I would like a full
keyboard for once in my life um so I finally and so yeah a
huge shout out to Razor um they reached out to me and was
like we really want to send you some gaming gear and I was
like me for free so yeah I got some free gaming gear I'm so
this is it's actually crazy um like skypad and Razor and
like many more he can't say anything it's actually crazy i
never had this opportunity before so i was like really
really surprised because it's like you know i thought that
like you know i don't know i just i just thought i was like
a nobody like no one really wanted me to you know represent
their brand or anything because i never had that opportunity
before so i was like really really surprised and stuff you
know why would I ever say no to free stuff it's free so yeah
it's actually crazy there's like so many things and that's
gonna happen in the future like so many amazing
opportunities I can't really I can't say anything about it
because like you know NDA reasons and like when it happens
it happens when it's announced it's announced but like a lot
of things definitely to look forward to by the way guys just
like you know this is just a beginning so yeah anyway today
we are gonna fucking play resident evil 4 and i hope to god
we can finish this game today i hope i will fucking finish
this game today oh my god there is like so much it might be
like fucking six more chapters six more chapters but we can
do this i believe You guys might be like, but Doki, it's
like 3 a.m.
Doki.
It's time.
Tell your phone in your boss and be like, I can't come.
Use your sick days.
You have one.
I know you have at least one sick day, but that's a joke.
Please don't like ditch work for me.
Please don't ditch work for me, guys.
Because working grants you money, and by having money, you
can pay for it.
for internet bills.
And by paying internet bills, you can watch me.
And then by watching me, you support me.
And then to support me, you have to go to work.
And then, yeah, it's a circle.
It's a circle.
Please don't skip work.
Ada?
Assuming you haven't.
I've got a tip for you.
The throne room.
Seems like something big is about to go down in the throne
room.
The throne room?
Where the fuck is the throne?
Oh my god, I'm so happy.
I don't have I don't have to deal with Ashley anymore I'm so
fucking happy no more Ashley okay let's see what do I have
okay I still have a lot of bullets that's good hello hello
sir I lost Ashley thank fucking god all right let's see uh
do I save up for the upgrade ticket should i save up for the
upgrade ticket or should i buy like the no i should save up
i should actually save up though let's see striker uh 38 000
how much money i do not have a lot of money okay is the
striker good is it worth it will that be old is it worth it
or nah is it worth it or nah guys this is very important
let's see one two three no Okay, no, okay, I won't use the
striker then.
All right, here you go.
Nixie, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Watching from work right now so I can afford super chats.
You know what's an even bigger brainplay?
Works so hard that you get promoted.
So...
Work so hard that you can get promoted.
And then by being promoted, you can watch me more.
Support me more.
That's the big brain play, guys.
Cal, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Watch Doki while working.
Infinite Doki glitch.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Alright.
Where do I have to go?
Okay, I have to go through...
Let's see.
Is there any, like, missions I need to do?
Oh, I need to go through that room.
Alright.
Is it...
This room?
right this is the room i opened yeah this is my room i
opened anything i love what's this oh the emerald nice free
shit i love free shit uh where the fuck is this room wait
where do i have to go okay the throne oh i have to go there
for the throne room which means our secret brave soul
willing to dispose of that monstrosity of a knight but b
warren is much stronger than the others he cut down our best
with a single strike it's okay i have flashbang do i have a
flashbang i do not have any flashbang amelia thank you with
the akasupa thank you thank you if i don't go to work then i
can't send yaka supers though so what is the real solution
here you go to work i i don't know what else i'm supposed to
tell i do have flashbang you go to work like what do you
want me to say oh no not the dark oh are you fucking kidding
me is Is this a library?
Is this a fucking...
Am I heading to the library?
No, this is the library.
Okay.
This is the...
What is this?
Is this the...
Oh, this is the night.
Okay, now it's dark.
It's okay.
I've gone.
I'm not as scared.
I'm not as scared, guys.
I have gone.
I'm not as scared.
Wait, how do I get this?
There's like...
Is this above me?
Okay, this is the second floor.
Okay.
I have gun.
I'm not as scared.
Where are you?
I know you're here.
Oh, this is it.
This is the Ashley room.
Okay, gun is always the answer.
Alright.
Where are you?
I have gun.
You can't fuck with me this time.
Where are you?
know you're here i know you're here because i screamed when
i was in here that's why i know all right ashley okay this
is where the night is all right i have an overdue book i
would go to the library to just rent out veggie tails i was
like the only time i ever go i only ever went to the library
to rent the arthur pc games and the vegetales potatoes oh
the third rat where's the third rat guys where's the third
rat i don't i forgot about the rat is above here
vegetales vegetales vegetales broccoli celery I always
forget that Veggie Tales was, like, super fucking religious.
I just thought they were funny veggies.
They were just funny veggies to me.
Back in the hall.
Oh, it's in the animal heads.
You're just silly little vegetables.
Where the fuck?
Oh, there you are.
Stop running.
Oh, my God.
Stop.
There you go.
I did it.
The Rad Exterminator is here.
yeah like did you guys know they fired the creator they they
fired the the creators of veggie tales not very christian of
them to do but that's what they did yeah yeah it's not very
show up about like christian values and then they fired the
creators.
Like, what the fuck?
No, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I should do listen to Doki while working.
Sadly, I can't always pay full attention to you, but I try.
Thank you, super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That's alright.
As long as like, you're still supporting me in your own way.
Oh, that has to be the merciless night.
It seems pretty fucking big.
Doki recognizes no God.
Only Larry.
Thank you for the super chat, Metti.
Thank you.
All right big boy.
Hello big boy.
That is a big boy Wait, they can run now What the fuck?
It's okay.
It's okay kick
It's okay kick and then run and then I
oh How am I missing?
How am I missing?
Okay, this is like fucked up a little bit because it's so
fucking dark.
What?
the fuck you so fast this is a little bit harder i just
realized how dark this is oh god it's okay i need to get all
of them out of the little hidey hole the fuck it's okay kick
come on get out of your little hidey hole wait what oh i
didn't see him i didn't see him i didn't see
Okay.
Please.
It's so dark.
It's so fucking dark.
I cannot see.
Ah!
Shit!
Okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
All right.
Okay, okay.
I'm going to use the shotgun.
Everything.
Everything shows up in the shotgun.
But let me take you first.
All right.
Oh, God.
Oh, the pellet.
Oh!
Shit!
Okay.
I'm just hoping all the pellets come out.
There we go.
That's fine.
Flashbang.
No, no, no, no.
That's not the flashbang.
You should be dead now.
There we go.
Easy.
So fucking easy.
Alright, there you go.
I don't think all of these guys are gonna try and kill me,
so we'll be fine.
And this is what the fish is for.
Fish.
Fish time.
Do I need to go here?
Do I need to?
I don't, right?
Pretty sure I don't.
I think I killed everything here.
I grabbed the loot there before.
Audubon, thank you for the gift of the ship.
Thank you.
No?
I'm pretty sure I got the...
Can't?
Alright, that was just for a bonus mission.
Alright, nice.
We're good.
We're good to go.
We got loot for the merchant.
There you go.
That's fine.
There is a gun in the library?
Where the fuck is that gun?
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you for the love of everything to made a
press alt on that inventory.
No.
I hope this pisses you.
you off even more no I don't need AI to help me sort my
inventory I don't need it I have I have my own skill okay I
want to go back to grab some stuff from
merchant i'm a gamer i'm not gonna let ai sort my guns all
right this way i'm gonna go sell my stuff this is my order
this is the doki order it's an it's art you won't understand
yay wait i got two oh yeah i got the rats too fuck I'm like
one short are you kidding me I'm like one short okay I might
as well like do this too uh yeah two of the same color I
might as well okay uh yes and then yes all right and this
one needs one two three I don't think I'm gonna get for
three of a kind oh I wasn't even gonna have three of kind
anyway all right we're gonna sell you yay time to save save
game all right we need to we need to go back to the library
anyway it's all right extra loot loot time i'm gonna reload
my shotgun all right it's time to go in and kill some more
knights open up I went the wrong way okay time to go back
this way and grab some more loot all right we gotta grab
that rifle is that rifle even good or is it just a sailing
rifle is that rifle just like money rifle it's just for
money right Oh, God, I hate this.
I hate that it's still so dark.
Someone turn on the fucking lights.
I know you're here.
Like, I know you exist.
Come on.
Walk over here, please.
Just walk over here.
Oh, there you are.
Thank you.
Thank you for walking over.
I really appreciate that.
over please thank you where's the other one where are they
not gonna walk over are they stuck no this guy's walking
over thank you i really appreciate that sir you get closer
you're way too far for me there we go boom all right can you
get closer it's convenient I don't want to waste my energy
Walk closer Okay, I know you're to my right There you are
You get a little closer Oh my god, the fucking statue Okay,
I think I hit him, right?
Okay, I don't know You get a little closer Nice, thank you
Thank you That's nice because I don't have to waste my
energy Okay Can you get a little bit closer?
Thank you.
Efficiency.
I love efficiency.
Alright, where is that fucking chest?
How many crows has Doki killed?
Not as much as I would like, even though they owe me so much
money.
We don't even have the key.
No!
I forgot to!
Ashley, you were supposed to unlock this!
Why couldn't you drop the key when you were getting
kidnapped!
Ashley, how could you?
Ashley didn't drop the keys when she was getting kidnapped.
So inefficient, Ashley.
So fucking inefficient.
Okay, this has to be the fucking...
Okay, this has to be the...
This has to be the...
Was it?
The...
Okay, I think this is it.
No.
The rifle.
uh this is how you do it nope nope not this way is it this
one no uh oh it's a square no is it like this i keep putting
oh here i did it i'm so smart
yay okay Fuck, okay.
God damn it.
Now I actually have it to inventory manage.
I can't believe it.
I let them win.
I hope you're happy, guys.
Now I actually have to inventory manage.
There.
Are you happy now?
You can tell I play Tetris.
That is the Tetris brain going on.
all right now i can sell this finally anything for gun I
know what game to start for next week because we do have a
lot of the steam memes oh my god I know what game I want to
start next week after we finish Resident Evil 4 I want to
finally play Dead Rise I know it's like Doki you bought so
many new games on your steam cell guys, but what about dead
rising Guys just think about dead which gun did I just
brought guys wait which gun did I okay is this is this a
good gun or no Um ugly.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
How did you get that?
I just gave my dungeon Is this a good gun or not?
Don't sell it?
Why?
Why, though?
Is it actually good?
Guys, I have so many guns.
Guys.
Yes, and there's so many guns, guys.
Little to no damage.
Okay, I'm selling it.
Alright, I'll sell the rifle.
It's too late.
I'm selling it.
Say, oh, seven.
Oh, it's time to oh, seven this.
Goodbye.
Alright.
Let's see.
I'll save my game.
I'm going to save here just in case.
Just in case I did make a mistake.
Just in case.
Alright.
Let's see.
Now we can progress the level.
Alright.
There you go.
be a journalist i've covered wars you know uh all right dead
rising is actually whoa what the what are you what jake jake
jake what oh my god there's bugs i just realized i never got
this far
got this far.
Alright.
This is locked.
Where do I go?
How do I get there?
Do I jump down?
Oh, there, there, there.
I can't believe it.
Mothmen.
Oh, God.
Jesus Christ.
I can't even loot them.
That's the worst part.
I can't even loot these fuckers.
Oh god, please tell me there's ammo here.
Oh, thank god, okay.
At least there's ammo for me here.
Oh, I need that.
I need that so badly.
I was running out of handgun ammo too.
Oh, thank god I'm on normal.
Thank fucking god.
I appreciate the simple things.
Being on normal difficulty so I have loot.
Thank fucking god.
the true horror oh but thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you to keep planning the cover wars you know
that's right it's time to be a journalist so I have an
excuse to play on journalist mode July 2 years since my
awakening Master Ramon has bestowed upon me a truly
righteous undertaking to improve upon the flaws of our human
form to seek perfection as observed in our siblings to this
because I shall will to this I cause oh I just like to this
cause what to this cause I shall willingly devote my life
January four years since my awakening my efforts to
transfuse the black liquid into the body or at the precipice
of success the womb is the key a pure soul proves to be a
highly malleable and adaptive subject he's talking about me
I'm so pure January six years since my awakening I was named
I've named these sacred larvae carried in the womb of the
chosen after my own they shall carry the prestige of my
family name as if I has spawned him of my own flesh the you
two are now the you two are they gonna be playing in in the
was it in the globe are now in the spear and are now close
to size of adult humans they continue to feed and multiply i
successfully created a new species master ramon has
recognized my efforts and blessed me with his praise he has
taken the you two calling them novice tadar meaning the
unseen i've been told that his holiness lord sandler himself
has also expressed pleasure with my work no bono Watch out
for their free albums.
The most horrifying piece.
One extraordinary honor this is.
I can hardly see the tip of my quill through tears of joy.
His humble servant.
This guy.
Alan, thank you for Super Chat.
Thank you.
Pure evil you mean.
Oh, he's talking about the red guys.
Those are the red rope guys.
Because they were like buggy.
next form of evolution return to bug honestly i feel like
bugs are like pretty pretty like uh uh what is it oh what's
the word they're pretty like hardcore in the evolution line
because they like there's like like you know like some bugs
they can't fucking die because they have like hard
exoskeletons and then they they like breed like crazy so
they can like produce like thousands and millions of insects
at once like the queen can just lay a thousand fucking
insects and stuff like and it's like what and then like
their tongue okay they're not they're like strong too like
ants they can like hold up like times 10 their fucking body
weight and stuff and they're pretty resilient yeah so like
in a way they are sort of like better than humans if they
were like human size i'd i would be very fucking scared
about a human size insect like that's the only thing there's
that that's the only thing that's stopping them they're just
too tiny if they were bigger if they were bigger then they
would be like scary they were they would actually be like
really fucking scary
They're so fucking tiny.
They will collapse.
You don't know that.
They're fucking buff as hell.
Wait, where did...
No, he dropped into the fucking hall!
Stupid bug.
Wait, I hear them.
Come on.
Oh my god, they reload.
Okay, it's stab.
There's always an end.
That's why I'm not afraid.
Oh, fuck!
Holy shit.
Give me a sec.
I didn't.
I didn't think there'd be more.
I thought there'd be an end.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
You fucking stupid bug.
I'm gonna stab you.
Aim for the eyes.
I don't know if you guys know this but bugs have a lot of I
oh thank God there's a lot of handgun ammo thank fucking God
okay see there is a lot of gear here oh they go this way all
of them that's one too many.
That's one too many.
Yeah, that's fucking right.
You can't fucking fool me.
I know a bug when I see one.
What the fuck do I get there?
Okay, not that.
Not you!
Except for you.
Just in case.
Pop.
Okay.
No, there's one more somewhere.
Aim for the lower left second from the third from the last
roll I'm reading chat
this is fucked up it's fucked up what the fuck I'm just
gonna stab you I'm gonna stab you that's fucking right I'm
gonna stab you that's fucking what are you gonna do that's
fucking right what are you gonna do that's fucking right
what are you gonna do that's right get stabbed everyone gets
one okay I'm looking I'm looking this time.
I'm looking.
Okay, I'm making sure.
I'm making sure I'm safe.
I got a hand grenade.
I know there's like, I'm missing loot here somewhere.
Where the fuck is it?
Welcome to London again.
Oh, there it is.
Right in front of me.
Alright, I need a heal.
I'm so fucked up.
I'm so...
Fucked up.
I'm gonna eat the fish.
Wait, actually, oh, wait, I am fucked up.
Okay.
I'm gonna eat the fish.
I was pretty fucked up.
Let's see, which way do I go?
What is that over here?
There's treasure over here.
I'm gonna go this way for the treasure.
Always for the loot.
What the fuck he's crawling?
Come on, that's right.
That's fucking right.
stab you stab stab whoa there you go you can't fool me this
time stab nice free loot free loot oh oh thank God okay okay
okay okay all right I was a little worried wait I hear
people behind me I hear you I fucking knew it I fucking knew
I knew you were there.
Let me stab you.
I'm gonna stab you too.
I'm gonna stab you.
That's fucking right.
No, wait.
Wait, that broke my knife?
Oh, I broke my knife.
Guys, I think I stabbed a little bit too much, guys.
Just a little bit too much.
It's okay.
I have my kitchen knife, though.
I still have my kitchen knife.
It's okay.
I got the kitchen knife.
What can they do about it?
Alright, let's grab this.
And then chest time.
Oh, nice.
Money.
I love money.
How do I get over there?
Please.
I just want to loot.
I forgot to upgrade my knife, please.
Okay, we need to...
Let me open this.
Open?
Open!
Shortcut!
Yay!
Is this a shortcut?
I'm gonna go back.
We need to fix my knife.
How else am I gonna be stabbing some bugs?
Alright, this way.
This way.
Merchant!
I need you to fix my knife.
I stabbed too many bugs.
I love shortcuts.
Tune up, repair.
Oh my god, I have no armor.
Okay.
I might as well upgrade the power and the durability here.
I feel like I'm going to be using this a lot.
I stabbed one too many bugs.
Equip.
Yeah.
That's right.
This has to be...
Oh, I go the right way this way.
All right.
There we go.
Back here we go.
Oh, shit.
I forgot to upgrade.
Oh, my God.
The only reason I had to come back.
I forgot to upgrade.
Oh, I almost forgot.
All right.
Trade.
Nice.
How do I upgrade this?
$100,000?
All right.
How much money do I have?
Oh, why?
Did I upgrade the knife?
Why did you guys stop me?
Why did you not stop me?
Okay, we're gonna...
Well, we have, like, so many of these.
Three of a kind.
All right, here you go.
Oh, it's the money or the ticket?
Oh, okay, that's good.
I can just use the ticket.
Okay, tune up.
Oh, I almost did the knife.
That would have been so embarrassing.
That would have been so fucking awkward.
Alright, let me sell the hornet and the butterfly lamb.
And then we should be good.
Imagine, though.
And then it turns into a knife only rabbit.
But the amount of money I spent on that fucking knife...
gonna turn into a knife-only run.
Back in it, we go.
Neil, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Bugs can't be human-sized because the oxygen density in the
air is too low to support them.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You're right.
This is why we have global...
To prevent the size of the bugs from growing bigger.
It's a risk.
Either fuck the environment or yeah the environment's fucked
but the bugs are smaller now guys just think about it just
just think about it chat yeah we might have fucked over like
we might have fucked over the world but now we don't have to
deal with like giant size bugs it's worth it it's worth it
Doki, please.
The priorities.
Alright, we gotta go this way.
Where are the bugs?
I don't like this.
This seems too bug-free.
I don't like how...
Wait, no, this is where I came from.
Sorry, I went the wrong way.
I...
Doki goes the wrong way again.
Yay!
It's this way.
This should be the right way, right?
Which I might be going the same way again.
Or was that the right way?
I can't.
I'm just way too confused.
Oh no no, I've never been here because there's a box.
I know I haven't been here because there's a box there.
I don't like how...
I don't like how bug-free this area is, though.
There we go.
I fucking knew it.
Give me a sec.
Melee!
That's fucking right.
Oh, stab!
Nice.
Alright, where's the other bug?
Where's the other bug?
I saw you.
I know you exist.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
There you go.
Where the fuck are you?
Where are you?
Closer.
Oh, fuck, but not that close.
Not that close.
fuck okay fuck you there we go i know i should like actually
shoot them because that was a waste of my health but like it
was worth it look i spent a lot of money upgrading this
knife chat a lot of money was spent on that knife okay we
can put this together we just need yellow herbs why is
yellow herbs so fucking hard to find i don't understand it's
like yellow
That should already be easy.
It's literally yellow.
You're the 1% who upgrades their...
No!
I'm pretty sure there's more people that upgrades their
knives.
Oh, that's a big one.
That took two shots to kill.
There's no way.
I can't be.
There has to be speedrunners.
Speedrunners can't be the 1% There's no way There's an
entire fucking charity event Dedicated to them It's like at
least 2% Guys At least 2% Yay Oh shit Holy shit you just
slapped me Okay we're definitely We're definitely gonna heal
now I'm gonna use this for you I don't know Alright, here we
go.
Is this the door I opened?
No?
Where the fuck did I open?
Where's the gate?
Oh, it's over here.
Okay.
This is the gate I opened.
Boop.
This is what...
No, this is...
This is...
Okay.
There's a ladder?
Oh, it's this way.
Alright.
No, we're not lost, guys.
We're never lost.
We're not lost, guys.
I just need to go up a ladder.
Okay, that's a bug.
I can tell.
I can fucking tell that's a bug.
Key time.
Alright, that should be both games.
Trust the process.
You just have to keep trusting.
Oh, drop down.
Drop down.
Alright, nice.
More handgun ammo.
That's really good that they dropped this.
It's like modern bug spray.
I'm not shooting the fucking thing again.
Yeah, I just have a gun.
I'm a better version of a knight.
Wait, was that it?
Bro, this could have been a text message.
Bro, you could have texted me this.
Don't you hate it when people just call you to give you,
like, one sentence of a message?
Bro, you're wasting my data.
Alright.
What do you mean this part?
Why are you giving me so much ammo?
this could have been an email honestly true i hate getting
into like calls for meetings i'm just like can't you just
text me this like i fucking hate it why is there a yellow
over there oh it's this okay that's one of them that's so
true though like just fucking text me you do not need me
Oh my god, where the fuck is the other one?
Where the fuck is the other one?
What's that?
That's just yellow ping.
Where is it?
You're gonna hate this?
Why do I hate this?
Oh, it's over here.
No, you know what?
I actually have unlimited data, but I should, like, use that
excuse.
I can be like, I'm sorry, I have limited data.
I'm trying to save money.
I stay as I'm...
That's actually such a good excuse.
Holy shit.
Wait.
If I want to get out of, like, calls and stuff.
Okay, here we go.
I'm just gonna stay here.
I have.
Well, I get, like, ganked.
No, right?
Oh, nice.
Crit.
Wait, is that?
No.
Guys, I fucked up.
Guys, I sort of fucked up.
But I can kill them.
Guys, trust, trust.
I can totally kill them.
Just gotta run.
I just gotta run.
This is fine.
I can totally kill these people.
Fuck!
Oh shit!
I didn't realize there were more of them!
Friendly fire!
Oh shit!
This is worth it.
This is so worth it.
Friendly fire!
Okay, this is fine.
This is fine.
This is so fine.
This is so fucking fine.
Do not worry.
This is so fine!
I told you!
Friendly fire!
Okay, nice.
One.
Ooh!
Come on, turn around.
Turn around.
I'm just going to kill this lady first.
This lady is annoying.
Friendly fire, friendly fire, friendly fire, friendly fire,
please.
There are so many instances of friendly fire.
How are you still people alive there?
Whoa!
Just kill each other.
Kill each other, please.
Yes.
Oh, no.
shit no not the guy ready fire oh my god yes kill all of
your friends
how how did you know
shoot the bomb what what noise your friend is making more
noise than i am making what the fuck are you still here
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
Oh, how the fuck did I like dodge that?
Yes!
Oh, thank god.
Oh my god.
Okay, there you go.
I'm just gonna kill him because I really can't be bothered
until this guy.
Oh shit!
all right nice all right okay it's just him it's just me and
him where is he where is he
where is he where did he go
oh there he is yes Yes!
Is he dead?
He's dead!
I did it!
I told you by the power of friendly fire.
I told you.
I knew it.
I knew friendly fire was on my side.
I fucking knew it.
Nice.
The Doki style.
The Doki style always works.
It might not be the traditional style.
But it always works.
It has a 100% success rate.
Alright, we need to make more shotgun ammo.
Let me see.
Craft shotgun shells.
Okay, nice.
Yeah, I gotta reload.
Wait, there's a bell?
I still don't know where the bell is.
All I know is to run.
That's all I need to know.
I don't need to know where the bell is.
I just need them to kill each other.
All right, here we go.
Gunpowder.
Oh, there's the bell!
We did it!
Found the bell!
We
did it!
Wow guys We fucking did it We found the best Alright let's
see There is Mine's over here There you go Nice Or this Oh
And then Boop Yay
The roundhouse kicker it's the thons oddball thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you the doki style 30 of time
it works every time is that ashley what she yelling about
what are you yelling about ashley
oh whose blood is that
oh oh who the fuck is that oh my god is the superior global
warming you failed me They're not resist.
Exactly.
Oh my god, are they like speed running?
Fast traveling?
It's like gotcha upgrades.
You know?
They paid a thousand dollars to make sure she level up
faster.
They can't wait the two hours.
Like you want to use this diamond to make her level 12.
Oh my god, no!
Wait, where am I fucking falling into?
Oh, shit!
Oh, this is like the pit.
Man, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It seems like very counterintuitive to have like a chain
down there.
Hang in there, Ashley.
Why the fuck do they have a chain there?
No, no, no!
Why is it so dark?
Why can't I just have lights?
Why can't they just light up the pit?
I don't understand.
Oh my god, I hate this.
Ah, fuck, okay.
Why can't they install lighting in here?
Who's gonna clean this up?
I was kidding.
Why is the cave fit not lit up?
I know!
Does it make sense?
Talk about sticking the landing.
Pro Leon.
Time and place, man.
Who are you telling this to?
Who?
It's just you and me and you don't even know I exist.
Okay.
There might be stuff here, right?
Does he have things?
No?
Why is there like a random indent here?
Oh my god.
Not a fucking dork.
This is the one Chris wants to continue to bloodline.
Whoa.
What the fuck was that?
What's that?
I think I hate most.
It's just the flashlight.
It's just so fucking...
It's still so dark.
Terminator.
Thank you, the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
How could this happen to me?
I made my mistakes.
I don't like this.
I don't know.
Ah!
Okay.
I hate this.
I hate this room.
pit what the fuck was that what was that what was that
Jesus oh my god that's the worst part it was so fast oh my
how the fuck do I shoot that it's just a little guy bro it
was so fucking fast
I feel like do they like do they have a queen those like
bugs am I supposed to kill the queen bug oh no why oh no I
see you like I literally see you get out
oh no jump in god fucking where are you where the fuck are
you I know you're here where are you i know you're here i
literally saw you swim oh my god i don't see it anywhere
okay what about i'm making some noise
oh i hate this i hate this so much god Fucking...
What's my HP?
God fucking damn it.
Okay, I'm gonna use...
I'll use my spray if I get hit one more time.
Alright.
Where are you?
Where the fuck are you?
God.
What is this?
What is this pathway?
Great.
Okay, off we go.
Pay attention to the water?
This fucking sucks.
god damn it get over here okay one bug down oh my god not to
look down gamers don't look down what is this bullshit
gamers don't look down oh shit I was so
down.
God damn it.
Alright.
Oh.
Can't believe it's trying to train me to look down.
What is this?
This is not made for gamers.
Not my game.
Not my Resident Evil!
There they go.
I wonder what's over there.
No, I'm not gonna risk it.
I don't even think that loot's worth.
deal it from here wait okay come on come on come on just
grieve it to me through oh my god i still actually has to go
there i actually have to there's some i don't want to eat
like fucking coarse fish guys they all the fishes here are
like marinated with bug bug juice and corpses why the fuck
would i ever eat any of the bugs any of the fishes here it's
there like they could have parasites okay anyway let's kill
eat this fish anyway anyway let's eat that one though that
one's okay that fish is okay could be yummy
that fish might have some parasites but that's okay sworn
dead.
How long has it been since I was thrown down there?
The meager scraps of food provided in the beginning are
gone, and they don't give us more.
The pains of hunger and thirst are unbearable.
Most have resorted to drinking the black water.
The first to turn was Herminio.
He was so weak that he couldn't even walk, but then suddenly
became mad.
By the time his rampage ended, two were dead.
I think we shouldn't drink that dark liquid.
Dear Abelardo has also passed, though he fought until the
very end.
The only thing I can do now is honor the bodies and pray
that their souls find peace.
Oh, Lord, why do you test us so?
If the creators of VeggieTales can get fired, there is no
guide.
The God is God.
Oh, hey, a craft.
How do I get that, though?
Oh, can I just, like, destroy it?
Kick!
God, my thighs.
God, God is dead.
Oh, finally, some yellow herbs.
All right, I need to put that here.
All right, up we go.
whoa what's going on is it because i'm a bug now is it
because i'm half bug and i'm getting drawn i don't oh my god
why why is i'm getting my shotgun out oh flashing lights let
me grab this gun just in case you know the flashing lights
is not very reassuring all right oh loot nice money money oh
red herb okay red herb there you go we have so many like the
red and green herbs even god can't defeat the final boss oh
humanity at late stage cap thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you oh the humanity not late stage
capitalism wait there's like a treasure here it's above me i
knew it i knew it was above me god damn it leon why is your
arm not long enough i'm so sad my my arm is too short short
arms short king Leon I go through here no oh my god merchant
merchant
merchant thank god you're here welcome all right we gotta
sell some holy shit okay do I have enough three okay oh wait
I have enough wait do I have like three of the same kind
wait okay what's the combination what's the combination that
i can do okay this is one two three four five okay two four
five two four five five of this five gemstones of differing
colors one two three i do what you need yellow round gem but
i just need two circles two four five two four five yeah i
could sell it for 2.0 don't wait oh i can't god damn it a
yellow i need a yellow gem i don't have a yellow gem i just
realized i forgot there's i thought i don't know it could be
two different shades of red no is that diamond wait no i
don't have enough spinalla god damn it i don't have enough
spinalla i'm just i'm just poor enough we were so close
out there's no i must have afk'd
oh no it meant the time we know i don't know i don't know if
that was like the amount of hours i spent on this game or if
it's like the time right now how long did i afk loot above
this door where there's no loot liar
Oh, you mean this.
Where is it?
I hear it.
Oh, there it is.
There you go.
Yeah, that's good.
Alright, here you go.
Near the merchant, there's more loot?
Or you meant that.
Oh, here, this guy.
Okay, yellow.
God damn it.
Hey, at least I can sell this, though.
I'll just sell this for now.
Just need the yellow.
I need the yellow diamond.
Okay, I'm saving anyway.
I'll cut me five reds.
Yeah, but I can have 2.0.
There must be another yellow diamond somewhere.
I'm not settling.
We're not gonna settle.
Illustration installation of the liquid nitrogen showers
that were requested last month has been completed.
Liquid nitrogen is an extremely hazardous substance.
Exposure may cause blindness, frostbite, and even death.
Handle with care.
Oh, wait.
That's not good.
It says maybe, guys.
Maybe.
I don't know.
I like those odds.
Maybe it's not guaranteed.
Okay.
It's not guarantee.
It's a maybe.
What's this?
What does this do?
Oh!
Hey, guys.
I figured out what the may...
See, I'm okay.
I told you it was a maybe.
Guys, I told you it was say maybe I'm still okay like see
didn't go blind
me me nine years since my awakening upon release of this
value uh black liquid shall enter my vein and circulate
through my entire body I expect this would be the most
painful experience of my life I await the trial with great
anticipation.
It is an honor to suffer through the holy labor of rebirth.
The next time I awaken, it would be as the true servant of
Master Ramon.
I make this vow.
I'll surpass the limitations of man and become a true
servant of God.
I'll find the heretics and serve as their executioner, their
vertigo.
Okay, that scared me a little bit.
I'm not gonna lie, I want to get close behind me.
Oh, hey, a lot of rifle ammo.
Wow.
Mm-hmm.
Is it him?
Oh, you the guy?
These people are not right.
That's not the guy.
Alright.
I don't like this.
Oh!
I really don't like this.
I really, really do not like this.
I don't feel comfortable I don't feel comfortable here It's
way too quiet
Oh I think I know Okay other service To conserve
electricity.
The power has been turned off for some equipment, including
the elevator.
It can be restored by flipping the circuit breaker located
at the very back of the laboratory.
Where's that?
Here?
Oh, it's here.
Okay.
I don't like this.
I don't like this at all.
I really don't like this.
Hello?
Oh.
Okay.
all right let me equip this okay okay where are you where
are you
Can I kill him?
Can I kill him with bullets?
Okay.
But can I kill him with bullets?
But you don't need to.
But he's a bullet sponge?
Okay.
Hello.
Oh my god, bro, fucking hell.
Get fucking out!
Where is he?
Hello.
Okay.
Where is he?
What
is this?
Okay.
Oh.
Where?
I can take another hit.
I hate this.
I hate this so much.
Oh my god.
Woo!
Chica!
Okay.
Oh my god.
I'm fucking...
God damn it!
It's just...
jump scares Is this a circuit breaker?
Oh power restored.
Thank fucking god
Where Where he's in the walls now?
Yes kick
Okay, okay, we can kill him.
It's pause
what What Looks like it's gonna take more than that.
What?
Okay, there's this.
I did I was like oh no Hey, please Hey, please Where is he?
Phase two?
What do you mean phase two?
What do you mean?
What do you mean phase?
Where is he?
Ah, he's behind me!
He's behind me!
Press,
press!
Ah, it's freaking!
Oh, it's freaking the fuck out!
There you go.
Are you serious?
Keep shooting.
He can die!
He can apparently die!
What the fuck?
Where is he?
Evade!
Okay.
Where is he?
Oh, where is he?
Evade!
Where am I gonna kill you?
I'm gonna kill you!
You can die!
Apparently you can die!
Ah!
Oh God, oh God, oh God, no, my legs!
Okay, it's okay Evade!
It can die allegedly.
What do you mean allegedly?
Oh God, is it magnum time?
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Yeah.
That's so fucked up.
Now he gets hit.
Oh, shit.
Son of a bitch.
Oh, fuck.
Yeah, it's not.
It's not.
Oh, my God.
Are you fucking?
No.
Get out.
Okay.
Come on.
I'm!
Help!
Oh, shit!
Invade!
I did it.
Oh my god.
Oh!
We did it, guys.
It only took my entire shotgun arsenal.
That's all it took.
Just all my shotgun ammo.
That's it.
It was just that simple.
It's just that simple.
Jesus Christ.
That was...
That was scary.
Oh my god, look, there's more shotgun ammo.
It's like I never lost my ammo.
Here we go.
It's like nothing bad happened that day.
Woo!
Yeah!
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you for the handsome bug man for all the toky content.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm glad you enjoyed my pure torture there.
Oh yeah, I should grab that loot.
loot right over here holy fuck jesus that was scary that's
so fucking scary all right oh nice the yellow i'm gonna go
all the way back to the merchant i don't care i'm gonna go
all the way back actually yeah i mean i could like save my
game as well okay one two three four five nice okay one two
and then three and then a blue we got it we have so much
money a hundred k let's fucking go we got a hundred k
dollars all right i could go to the elevator but like money
it's time for money
oh that was so scary she's oh i forgot uh i'll go back there
soon i need a i need a set wait oh where's the where's the
door oh my god the door is locked look at the door are you
serious he fucking destroyed my door what's wrong with you
you monster look look i
I could look over the murder, but destroying my door, that's
fucked up, yo, that's fucked up.
I am okay with you fucking making an army of, like, murder,
suicidal bugs, but destroying my door.
That's uncalled for.
That's so fucking uncalled for.
All right, he's near the elevator.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, I can sell.
Nice.
All right.
Yeah, so fucking rude.
Unforgivable.
That's all right.
We got the merchant here.
I'm looking at my arm.
I know it's pretty...
What about my legs?
Oh, shit.
Oh my god, he's in my heart.
bring him in just as it has for our newest daughter who has
joined us in communion Ashley you can keep her
my faithful disciple will show her the bad look if this is
about Ashley you can keep her bad deliver to these vagrant
children their salvation as you wish
Oh, I can see what's going on.
I'm connected to the hide mind.
Bro!
I'll make it cheap for you.
Oh!
It's the homie!
Oh my god, it's the homie.
87%.
Nice.
Okay, ship to save.
I knew he wouldn't ditch me.
Bro's for life.
My man.
wait that's it yeah what the did he do what happened in
between what happened between these scenes how did you
administer this in that case we know what we have to do just
homie stuff you know you wouldn't understand Doki.
Yeah.
It is in it for you.
Can he die?
Can I just make him do everything?
Wait, he's like free ammo.
Make your way to the surface.
Let me get some ammo real.
I need to know.
Can I use him as a meat shield?
he die what a try i mean i can save ammo i can i can save
ammo if he doesn't die yes and no homies never die true rob
good job killing the bug god but did you know you could
froze him look it's not about we're not here to make it easy
okay we're here to send a message to all the other bugs down
there.
Today was the worst day of my life.
It's my daughter's fifth birthday.
But here I am stuck on a mangy boat heading out to some
backcountry dump.
If it weren't for the pay, no one would be willing to work
in the middle of nowhere.
Those in the, that's true, that is true.
The pay is really, really good.
I'm like, like, I can work anywhere.
Those in the castle are always reminding us to take care
during the excavation But a few workers collapsed after
inhaling some dust.
Oh no.
Asbestos.
You're gonna get cancer.
There's something going on here, but they're not telling us.
There's too many secrets.
I started coughing too.
I should sleep.
Something's really wrong with me.
I threw up blood three more times today.
And I'm so weak.
No, he's getting it.
He's got the abestos.
It's not Oshas.
save shit i never should have come here i came here for the
money but instead i am the one paying the price i'm a
terrible father i'm so sorry sweetheart you deserve better
october since morning head don't work why more blood threw
up many insects crawling i hear a voice a fine data work
digging brings me so much joy I am full of happiness.
I offer it all to you.
Everything for you, Lord Sadler.
Jesus Christ, this is a cult.
All right, trade.
Is there anything new?
Gold token?
Oh, it's the prize of stuff.
Everything else is like not as interesting.
All right, sell time.
Okay, I can sell this, this.
A gold frame, monocle.
Okay, yeah.
Oh my God, I'm so rich now.
oh my god now i'm double the tax bracket all right is there
anything interesting that i don't have yet uh striker okay i
have i don't need any of these where are the recipes then it
said like new recipes i don't need any of the resources i
have like plenty of shit right now so i can tune up all
right it's tune up time okay my armor yes my armor's fucked
up right now uh i'm gonna to upgrade my power for uh let's
see actually power for i think power for the shotgun and
then yeah i'm gonna upgrade the power for the shotgun and
then the power for the pistol uh yeah that should be good
and then oh i can upgrade the oh i can fully upgrade all my
guns I can upgrade all my guns.
Okay, power on the riot, too.
Yeah.
On the riot gun.
Okay, and then...
I think we can...
We need to start to slowly upgrade...
Oh, it's okay.
I still did it.
I might have accidentally got the guns confused, but it's
okay.
It still works.
Okay, I guess I'll...
I feel like I use the shotgun more, so I'm going to...
two more i guess like reload for this all right this is good
we're good we should be good now oh dear i wonder if i can
there's new guns to do this for i wonder are there new guns
for this new game which one is it this red right red
punisher okay watch this actually so much practice with this
why is it so slow is it because of my gun upgrades look at
that no okay so no that's not bad i'm about to reload that's
not fair what the fuck i don't have enough
okay oh my what okay stop stop stop What is this?
Stop!
Stop watching!
Oh, I didn't shoot the TNT?
That makes a lot more sense now.
That actually...
That actually makes a lot of sense.
Guys.
I don't know why I didn't think of that.
I was like, wait a minute.
Why?
Why is it that difficult?
What do you mean?
He fucking...
Are you serious?
Gamer of the Year, by the way.
Oh, if it's...
Oh, it does like...
Oh!
I...
Oh.
Okay.
I didn't realize that's how they were going to line up.
That's actually it.
I didn't know this gun had, like, go through people.
There we go.
Nice.
That's good enough.
We don't need to do any more.
You know, that's fine.
We got three.
That's all we need.
All right, what is it?
Oh, that's a gray.
20.
God.
Damn it.
Look, it's because the homie was watching me.
I got nervous.
Chat.
Don't you get nervous when the homie watches?
Yes.
The homie was watching.
Of course I got a little nervous.
Where the fuck is the... Wait, was there no, like, keyboard?
I'm not keyboard, sorry.
Oh, type.
Is there no typewriter?
Yeah, I got Dormant's anxiety.
Hard for me to put my faith in someone who used to work for
Umbrella.
I
don't need to worry about them.
Yeah, they went bankrupt.
That's fine.
What are you after?
I just want to feel good about myself.
Keyboard of the past.
Prehistoric keyboard.
See.
I think I'll go here, right?
Subobjective.
So I can...
I'm gonna go...
Go the right side for now.
Oh, yeah.
What?
What's this?
Oh, I have to go to the right.
It's a TNT.
The diamond has been relocated.
When using explosives, cave-ins are a frequent occurrence.
Keep your distance from the blast zone.
In the event of a disaster, clean up immediately.
Ensure adequate numbers of staff are on site.
Don't worry.
I'll definitely clean it up.
She didn't clean it up.
Alright.
Where the fuck are the...
Where the fuck are the cult people?
Shoot them.
Oh, it's the villagers!
I mean, why am I scared of?
I have my boy!
Okay, that is bullshit.
My boy is here.
Where is... I'm gonna shoot his leg.
Oh.
Alright.
Got his knees, and then...
There you go.
That's how I do the headshot there.
How do I get out of here?
Oh, vault.
There we go.
Nice.
It's fine.
We have the homies to help me out.
See?
Is that a chainsaw?
It's not a chainsaw, right?
It's not it, right?
There we go.
Did I hurt him?
Okay.
Oh, I didn't realize that didn't cross over.
That is my...
Oh, shit!
That's chainsaw, man!
Believe me, I know.
It's okay, that's when you're here.
Oh!
This is what...
That was my kick!
I can't believe it.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I'm fine.
I'm fine.
We're fine.
This is good.
Shoot him!
What the fuck?
It's okay.
Snap, snap, snap, snap.
I upgraded my knife.
Step, step, step, step, step.
There you go.
All right.
It's fine.
I upgraded my knife.
I can do that now.
Okay.
Homie!
You're supposed to help!
Bro!
Oh, shit.
Okay, stab.
Stop.
Hey.
Nice.
Wait, you're still shooting somebody?
You know, bro, it's fine.
Oh!
It was not fine.
In the end, it was apparently not fine.
Okay, I have my legs for this.
Are they all dead?
They must be all dead, right?
Then I killed everybody.
Yeah, see, I told you.
It's so easy.
Just kill everybody.
Heavy grenade.
Is it heavy grenade?
Oh, fuck.
Wait, that's... Okay.
This is what this is for.
Alright, is he gonna drop down?
What's a woman, chain solid, man?
Alright.
There we go.
It's okay.
She can't see.
She has a bag on top of her.
That's fucking right.
Take off that bag!
You would have known I was here!
If she took off that bag, she could have known.
It was not very efficient.
She wasn't a very efficient chainsaw woman.
Man.
Alright, nice.
We got some ammo.
And then we open the door.
Wherever that is.
That's the bridge.
And then we...
Steal their loot.
Oh, what?
Where?
It's okay, he's got this.
I'm just gonna open the door.
Don't worry.
What the fuck?
Why is he aggro to me?
There he is.
Shoot him.
You can do this.
I believe in you.
This is bullshit.
Bro, shoot!
Bro, what the fuck?
Bro, I could have knifed him.
At least he's more...
He is more useful than Ashley, though.
I have to admit.
Like, if only they could just give Ashley a gun.
Like, that's all Ashley needs.
She just needs a fucking gun.
The world will be easier if they gave a child a gun.
In-game, by the way.
all right nice all right all right we're just gonna get rid
of this guy all right he's dead nice don't p.s don't ever do
that i said in game i am absolved of any legal matters by
saying that
All right, we gotta go this way.
Gotta go this way.
Okay, there's a chest over here, though.
Yay!
Ooh!
Golden hourglass.
Nice.
That works.
Your Honor, she said- Oh, shit!
Okay, look at that reflex, though.
Oh, my- look at that flick, though!
That's when you know I'm gaming.
That's when you know.
That was an insane flick.
That was a headshot flick too.
The gamer aim.
Wait, how do I get to the other side?
Wait a minute.
Do I go from above?
Yeah, fear makes me aim better.
Oh, I can.
Okay.
Oh, I think I can.
Yeah, I can just drop down.
Drop down.
Yay!
Here I go.
Alright, bro.
Let's go.
We gotta explode this.
Yes.
It's nice that they marked the stone for me.
It's like, tic-tac-toe.
oh okay i'm okay where did he go oh okay then yeah it would
be very unfortunate if he got crushed there you sure you're
just a researcher you do not look like a researcher yeah so
average guy so what an average guy working for umbrella corp
so Has the fucking cure for the larvae people.
So average.
Your average Joe.
Alright, this way.
Just need to paint your past yellow.
And Leon is ours.
Ah!
Holy shit!
Oh my god.
Bro, my arm's gonna get ripped off.
Boy, you're gonna fucking be stronger.
than the troll jesus christ now you owe me oh yes no no no
no you may be get grabbed first what do you mean now you
there's two there's two
there's two oh my god where where do i Shoot!
Oh god, oh god, oh there he is!
There it is!
Gotta shoot that bike!
Okay, don't worry, I got the rifle.
Oh, that's unfortunate, that's unfortunate, that's...
Oh fuck, that is!
Oh my god, where am I?
What happened to me?
There we go.
Oh god.
Oh shit, I gotta go up!
Melee!
Mike, thank you for the Akasufa!
Thank you!
Oh, I got it!
One troll down!
I- he's dead?
Is he dead?
I can't tell.
Okay, he's dead.
He's dead.
How?
How do I?
Lewis!
Shoot him!
Where do I shoot him?
Where's his head?
Where?
Okay.
Where do you think you're going?
Wait, yeah, where are you going?
Wait, he's not!
He's not!
He's not stuck anymore.
He's not stuck Guys he was not stuck anymore
Don't waste ammo
Oh God shoot him shoot it Why me you have a better angle.
Okay
okay all right let's finish this why me you literally have a
better angle
we did it yay we killed the troll oh my god yellow diamond
Jesus Christ, why the fuck?
I don't...
Please, Luis, I did...
You could have shot him.
You could have...
Why did you make me shoot him?
You had ammo.
I know you had ammo.
You have unlimited handgun ammo.
This fucking freak.
He could have been like...
Leon, don't shoot your gun!
Distract him!
You guys said that.
That's all he had to say.
All right, loot.
Okay, there's some more ammo here.
All right, nice.
And then grenade here.
Let's see.
Wait.
Where is that grenade?
Oh, it's over here.
Wait, there it is.
What the fuck?
And then...
Oh, it's nice.
Some ammo to sell.
this what are you doing open this door did he do it
am i supposed to go back it was it was please i'm
directionally challenged oh he did it oh thank god he
actually did it he fucking did it what on madman what will
win with a million who would what would what would with a
million dollars two trolls at the same time thank you Thank
you.
I was supposed for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, that's where they found it.
It's like, like, it's a Jurassic Park.
They're trying to do another Jurassic Park.
But with, like, scarier bugs.
Oh.
We're okay.
Can I make more?
Oh, yeah.
I can definitely make more shock and shells.
I swear I'm just making... Well, it's all just green herbs.
Please.
please there's other colors in the world all right you're
not suggesting me ride this thing do you see any other way
oh my god leon you don't understand it's to raise the bro
bond leon you don't understand we're gonna be so close after
this what are you calling this is it this is a turning point
of our relationship i have to shoot oh no oh no i have
unlimited ammo what am i gonna be shooting
okay i don't know ready that weapon oh okay This way?
Wait, I I'm so confused What else what else is gonna come my
way?
Is there anything behind me?
Okay, we're okay.
We're okay.
What the fuck is this mini game?
That is this dovetail shit like It's okay.
We're fine Get down!
Get down, Lewis!
Oh my god.
At the lead end, shoot!
Please!
What is your job?
What is your job, Lewis?
Jesus Christ.
I have to do everything.
Yeah, this is Tempo M2.
Fucking a tempo run right now.
We're in a tempo run.
Oh, right.
Alright, nice.
Dead.
What are you doing?
Get off the fucking ramp!
Wait, what if I just run him over?
Can I just run this man over?
Like, why was I so scared?
Why the fuck was I so scared of him?
My card is...
There we go.
My card must have been stronger than this.
Like...
There's no way.
Yay!
Probably would have grabbed the cart.
Bro, this cart is going, like, at least...
Okay, one mile per hour.
It's not that bad.
It's not that fast, but, like, it should be fast enough.
It should have been fast enough.
Oh, that was easy.
Put the phone down and drive.
Great knots.
Things are just getting started.
Yeah, wait, he had dynamite?
Okay, I did not know he had dynamite.
Okay, you're right.
I would have died I would have died Now if you told me he
had dynamite then that would make sense What the fuck?
What?
Where is he?
What the fuck there's a door there?
How the fuck did he come from?
Sorry must have slipped that's fine it's fine wait he's
gonna explode himself right so where is he oh no he's still
alive nice all right free loot free loot yay wait i hear oh
my god thank god there's that loot
Where's the...
I hear it.
But where is it?
It's above me?
Oh, it is.
I knew I heard you.
Fucking knew it.
I could always hear the loot.
Okay, shotgun.
Let me have to go this way.
This way, Lewis.
This way.
Barrel.
Nice.
Oh, my God.
Not again.
how about i drive and you shoot how about that why don't we
swap
why do i have to shoot the gun i don't understand oh god god
i'm trying my best You're not tilting!
Oh, fuck!
Okay, this is actually bullshit because I can tell that he
was also not helping me.
Oh my god, there's two!
He was also not helping!
Do you not see that?
Alright, nice, we did it.
Oh yeah, I see the dynamite now.
I never see it.
He's the moral support.
He's just takes cover.
Oh!
Please!
I know!
Lewis, you have to help out too, Lewis.
Like, please.
That's all I want.
Lewis, Lewis, you shoot.
You shoot.
Ha ha!
What the fuck?
What's that?
Okay, nothing was going to come behind me.
That's good.
That's all I need to know.
I need to...
Jesus.
Like, how?
Oh, shit, reloading.
Alright, it's fine.
Like, does he die?
Can I kill him?
Hello.
Oh, shit.
Okay, he does die.
Thank God.
Please, I'm reloading.
Alright, we're fine.
Oh, shit!
I don't know!
You have a gun, too!
I just don't understand!
Why is he saving ammo?
Hello.
Nice weather we're having here.
Alright.
Nice.
we're alive i'm moving as fast as i can
all right nice we're alive no no no no no no oh we're not
we're not we're not i'm pushing
that is where i'm looking
what's that break.
Lewis, you have one job, apparently.
Lewis!
You fucked up your one job!
That was literally the only thing you have to do!
I just did 99% of that work.
The cards.
Give us a three to one next time, hey, Sancho?
Get pussy.
Jesus Christ.
I don't know, bro.
Look.
Look, bro.
I know you're my best, bro.
Even though we knew each other for, like, less than a day.
But, bro.
I don't know, man.
Maybe my mom was right about you, man.
I don't know if we could see.
I don't know if you can come under my house anymore, man.
Bro.
Give me a break.
We can make it if we can.
circle around you circle around oh i guess we no where do we
circle we drop down where the do we circle around oh okay we
drop down okay sorry i forgot i didn't see the yellow paint
the journalist yellow paint all right let's see there's a
ladder here
here we go all right bro let's go thank god you have gun
though what the oh my god bro shoot him bro shoot him oh my
god they're back
they're back that's fucked up wait oh he shot someone it's
fine my bro's got me right you got me right bro bro you got
me right bro okay he's got me oh thank god okay okay i can
finally combine some herbs jesus christ okay we have a lot
of too many have lost their lives and never-ending swarm of
insects please destroy the entrances in their gigantic hive
and save us from further tragedy okay but like where like
how first off where and also how instructions unclear do you
think i double tap whoa i'm not wasting my ammo i know what
to do
that's right that's right i know what to do That's right,
it's all me stabbing tab Stab, stab, stab, stab, stab, stab,
stab, stab, stab, stab Nice, where's the other one?
I swear I saw one more, where is it?
There you go Oh shit!
Don't worry That's fucking right, yeah I do!
That's fucking right!
Welcome to London!
I hope you enjoy the king.
There you go.
Nice.
Is there more?
Jesus Christ, what the fuck?
He's like crawling now.
Get out of here.
Nice.
Alright.
I need a fucking...
Okay, I actually have to use my gun now.
I'm running out of like...
I'm running out of knife juice.
There's almost no more knife juice, guys.
Alright, we need to refuel our knife.
Okay, let's see this way.
Destroy the hive.
Where's the hive holes?
I don't even know what it's supposed to look like.
Is it that this?
Oh, that's the hive.
Oh, it's yellow.
The journalist yellow.
figured it out guys it's the journalist yellow again it's
always the journalist yellow all right we figured out what
it is okay i'm gonna explode this because all right there
you go all right we figured it out my shoulder's hurting
apparently uh the reason lewis didn't shoot is because
you're actually using his gun he didn't notice a swap
because you're also using the Oh, shit, Nuts!
I can't believe Lewis is... Why does he get... Yeah, he's an
average guy, but yet he gets unlimited ammo?
That's so fucked up.
Okay, I thought that was a natural bug.
That's not fair.
Why does the average guy get unlimited ammo?
He can't be average if his gun is unlimited.
Chaonix.
No, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, let's see.
Oh, there's the last one.
Nice.
We did it.
We destroyed the hive holes.
Oh, the holes are gone.
Plug the... It's like popping a pimple.
You know, I'm just... I can't be bothered to kick.
I have to...
too much ammo.
All right, let's see.
Where does this way go then?
Wait, this is where I'm supposed to go.
All right, let's see.
Yay, money!
Just in case.
Yeah, fucking knew it.
I was like, why is there a suspiciously placed...
Uh...
Suppliciously placed...
What are they called?
Gas canister here.
Hmm.
Alright, lights.
Where are they?
Where are the bugs?
You're a real rock.
I don't know, man.
Is that actually a real rock?
Oh my god, it was.
It was a real rock.
I can't.
I'm super paranoid now.
I can't believe it was real.
I can't believe it was real this entire time.
Alright, get out.
There's more?
Okay, I definitely don't need loot here.
Oh, shit!
Get down.
Any more?
No?
Alright.
Nice.
Try to make sure there's none that's gonna fucking surprise
me.
What?
Where did you come from?
Oh shit!
That's where you came from.
I was like, what?
What does that sound?
Any more?
Any more bugs?
Okay, I got all the hives.
Alright, up we go.
It's time to go up.
Bro, you fancy.
I'm beat.
Makes you appreciate tech like this.
I don't get you.
Why risk your life like this?
Upies.
You don't know us.
I told you.
It makes me...
Pass the merchant?
Be straight with me for once.
Los Illuminados.
I was working for now.
See?
There was a horn?
Helping the...
of you doesn't make up for it.
I know that.
But still, I don't want anyone else to get hurt.
In that case, you better get serious.
Harsh words for a swire.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe I missed out on the merchant.
.
Gus, if I made it all this way, you know it means we're
almost...
Oh!
Almost what?
Oh, Lewis!
Oh, shit, it's this guy!
Major Krauser?
What the hell?
What the fuck?
Why?
Bro, that was my job!
Oh, I'm stolen goods.
and killing a few rats along the way easy work Ashley it was
you catch on quick oh did I teach you knives are faster no I
use my knife on the fucking bugs bro my knife's gonna break
it's gonna touch your skin and break
This reminds me of the Resident Evil gunfight Where you just
run around and then nothing happens
We fight with the kitchen knife
We are just getting started, rookie Wait, do I actually have
to fight with Are you fucking kidding me?
Bro, my knife is about to break!
I used it on the bug why didn't anybody stop me bro why
didn't anyone stop me
bro I actually used up maturity of my fucking
bro I'm bro my fucking knife Bro.
Okay.
That's a major.
Wait, what the fuck?
Where did he go?
Oh shit!
How?
Right here.
I can understand.
What happened was?
Oh.
Unforgivable.
But that doesn't give you the right to hurt innocent people.
Nice.
Come on, I'm trying to take you to the edge.
I'm assuming that I can, like, just kick you off.
Yes, yeah.
All right.
I don't know.
My knife, that's a...
Yes!
No, I can't!
God damn it!
You're alive!
You mean I could shot my gun this entire time?
No, play, Rookie.
You haven't changed a damn...
Bro, bro, bro, his thighs are thicker than mine's.
Bro, why didn't you warn me that knives weren't for bugs?
Bro, it's not the ladies that are gonna be at loss.
and remove those damn parasites.
It's not just the ladies, bro.
Bros before os.
You know, I led a pretty shitty life.
But now, eh?
I think, Leon.
People can change, right?
No, bro!
Bro!
Oh, I thought he was gonna hold his hand.
He's just kidding.
I was like, damn, what did happen during that cave time?
Holy shit, what happened in that cave?
I bet the accuracy is from the fucking it's from the knife
fight One last moment
All right next Okay, you just ruined I improved the moment
Give her a fine night, Don Quixote Secret cave video
I did You won't get away with this Krauser All right, let's
spend one.
Let's look at him while I use the bathroom, guys.
I'll be right back.
Sheep, Luca, and Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
He's just, he's just faking it, guys.
See, there's no blood.
He's just having a rest.
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
She's not looking right now.
Out of hands of all you dragoon pros.
Yeah, yeah, not looking.
by the way thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
all right i think it's time to actually fix i think it's
time to fix my inventory a little bit let me all right here
i have like two spaces oh my god i can't believe i wasted my
knife on the fucking bugs on why did you guys say anything!
None of you said anything!
Oh my god.
Okay, up we go.
Okay.
Oh, up we go.
We don't need the merchant.
We have gun.
You did not ask.
There's only time to say this once, so listen up.
They took your friend to the top of the clock tower.
A friend?
Ashley?
Bro, I don't want to be friends with, like...
Ada, you have to be very careful of your wording right now.
Leon is like 20-something.
Ashley is like a tween.
I don't want to be a friend with a tween.
This is a job.
Ada, this is a job, Ada.
What the fuck do you mean?
okay uh let's see from the even the very sight of his image
makes my she's in college she does not look like bro she's i
think he's because of the skin i have she looks like i she's
wearing hot topic shit like i assume she's a tween like okay
um it's the hot topic guys even though this image makes my
skin crawl do me a service and find some way to deface the
portrait of him in the room shown in the photo photograph
will you it's not particular how how did you do it hitting
it with something might do the trick ramon's portrait where
the fuck is this i don't know where this is someone help me
recover a stolen jewel snatched by a thieving crow i bet it
can be found in the vile things nets it's an heirloom of our
family cannot become some kids oh it's in the courtyard I
see you took care of a request.
Yeah, I did.
It's in the throne room?
Alright, it's the throne room.
Yay!
Okay, I can get rid of this.
And this.
Okay, bro, I have so much stuff to sell.
Oh, I should do that real fast, too.
Uh, gemstones.
I can put two...
Actually, I should put the blues.
Actually, no.
Two of the reds.
Actually, one of the reds?
I'll do two of the reds.
reds.
Do I do the reds?
No.
I think I can do... I don't know.
I feel like I can put, like, all of the kind of... Alright,
let's plug it.
I'll do two of the reds.
Alright, I'll sell this, and then I'll sell...
Keep a chicken.
Does it look like I have... I've seen some chickens here?
What I think does it... I don't think there's any chickens
near me.
Okay, we don't need the submachine gun ammo.
We don't need the bolts.
And I think that's everything?
Oh my god, I have nine of these.
Eh, it's fine.
Maybe one day.
One day I'll use it.
One day.
Let's craft a chicken.
Let's see.
I'm gonna grab the reload speed of molding a weapon Let's
see.
I'm gonna...
I feel like I'm gonna up the power.
Whenever we get to a boss fight, this would be useful.
Don't get yourself killed now.
Alright, save game.
Nice.
Oh.
Alright, where's the throne room?
It's all the way over here?
Block treasure.
Oh, fuck.
Let's go.
I might as well.
I mean, there's no way there's people here, right?
I killed everything.
Right?
I should have killed everything, I'm pretty sure.
What was the other mission I have to do?
I have to kill something.
I did.
I fixed the knife.
See?
It's fixed already.
Oh yeah, the pawn.
Gotta define the pond, too.
Where's the area?
Oh, it's over here.
Is that the, yeah, the throne room.
Alright.
We need to get the emerald in the courtyard and then the...
We need to deface the portrait here.
We might as well get that over with.
It might be useful.
Later.
Oh, hey there.
Hey, guys.
I'm just gonna...
Boop.
all right oh shit what the fuck i didn't know you were here
too whoa shit they can't go through the door they can't go
through the door i win
it's fine they can't they're afraid of the door nice don't
you love it when they can't walk through the door oh my god
what the fuck they do oh shit oh my god what the fuck my
shoulder bro I need to aim up that alright it's fine how is
the door still It just works.
Oh, hey, there's a vase here.
Boop!
Nice.
All the ammo I used earlier.
Alright.
Time to deface this portrait!
Hello.
Surely there's nobody in this room, right?
Surely, right?
Surely I'm safe, right?
Right, guys?
Hmm.
chicken oh my god I have to get an egg there's two chickens
why there's so many chickens
my lord my true benevolent father blessed the thousands of
bloodline with an iron hammer the founder of my family
proclaimed the holy teachings of lust evil and persecuted
its followers not only that he stole their most prized
possession and sealed it below the castle blasphemy
insolence how long have i suffered the shame of knowing that
the same blood flows through my veins finally the day of
atonement has come oh my beloved lord sadler i shall release
the holy plagues you were hidden under the castle the time
is now with divine grace the wicked shall be reborn as a
part of the flock.
Reborn Escanado, they shall be my Lord's loyal servants.
Nothing will please me more than to sit at my Lord's feet
and bask in your splendor.
I am your humble servant.
You are my eternal light.
To you, I swear my unwavering allegiance.
Chicken.
Is this it?
Did I do it?
Is this his family?
Oh, this is his family.
Why can I?
Am I not defacing it?
Why isn't it?
Oh, it's the egg?
Oh, wait.
I don't know if I should be sitting here.
Hmm.
Thank you, chicken.
Okay.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Okay, equip.
All right.
There we go.
Thank you, Chicken.
Oh, Master Ramon, for tomorrow's procedure, I shall finally
surpass the limitation of of this moral shell what's left of
me now shall soon be gone magnificent the holy body is a
wondrous miracle the feltiest sworn to master ramon is the
sole light that illuminates my path our fate shall be
entwined until the very end have you ever known such loyalty
all right do you have the golden egg chickens can you lay me
the golden egg apparently this is very important.
Does it have to be golden?
Can it be any type of egg?
Does it have to be a golden egg?
It has to be golden.
Where the fuck?
Lay your fucking eggs.
Lay your eggs!
Paint it on yellow.
Alright, I'll do this puzzle.
It has to eventually lay the egg while I do this puzzle,
right?
Eventually it'll start laying eggs.
okay that's not it no that's not it either this no god damn
it is this one no okay this one here you oh
there's a golden egg all right i'll throw this one all right
can you lay a regular egg or because i don't want to use my
golden egg can you guys lay regular okay if i sit in here
egg for me.
Chicken.
Where are you chicken?
Where are you?
Yeah, but what if I can just throw a regular egg?
Why do you guys have performance anxiety?
Why now?
Alright, we'll save the golden egg.
I'm totally gonna Miss.
Guys, I want to back up Egg just in case.
What if I miss?
Guys, you know it could happen.
You know I might accidentally miss.
If you miss, just miss.
Lay the Egg.
Sit down.
lay your egg sit sit oh it's gonna do it it's gonna do it
it's gonna do it right here lay that egg come on come on oh
get out all right okay now i won't miss guys i have a
practice throw i have a practice throw does a normal egg
work guys does it have to can i Dude, normal eggs work,
chat.
Acting like the chicken is a dog.
No, it has to be good.
God damn it.
Okay, guys, we're going to use the brown egg as a practice
throw.
Just in case.
I don't know.
I have a feeling.
stupid i can miss like what if i miss all right what was the
other mission i already forgot what the other mission was
okay request okay request uh which one have i not completed
okay dual thief snatch but oh my god you're fine oh shit i
got killed all of you oh my god how are you I'm still alive!
Did I not kill all of you?
Oh, there's more.
That's why.
There's more.
How did you guys show up?
Oh my god!
Oh, I didn't miss guys.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Double tap.
Alright.
what the fuck Jesus Christ at least that's free money all
right down here and then there's the courtyard all right
time to get that is it just one crow chat how many is the
crow easy to find that's my biggest question is the crow
easy to fine that's what i'm worried about
all right let's save just in case it's in the nest it's
around the merchant area which one this one the courtyard's
right in front of me
that's you isn't it that's wasn't that crow guys it wasn't
that crow guys you don't even have loot this crow doesn't
even it doesn't even have loot it's not loot crow
i was supposed to follow him oh oh he's back alive
He's alive!
It was just a flesh wound!
Guys!
I told you.
It was just a flesh wound, guys.
It's okay.
He lives.
He was just being dramatic, chat.
He burned Jesus.
It was just a flesh wound, chat.
knew I could I wasn't my fault oh give me that fish give me
that big bass okay all right there's another one oh my gosh
there you go all right this is a little dirty here okay
let's see okay I need look how much okay all right we're
gonna figure we're gonna figure this out get a tetris this
we're gonna figure this out we're gonna figure this out
let's see i'll just mix all the green herbs yeah i'll do
that and then there we go oh bump but i don't but i don't
but i don't but i don't but i don't but i don't bum bum bum
bum
you i told you guys wait is that another fish no doki you
have a problem doki you have a problem y'all get yeah i
can't i get rid of all this fish you can't keep you can't
keep killing all the fish doki yeah you got the beta i i and
i sold it for money instantly Alright, let's go...
Let's go turn in these quests.
Yay!
Trade.
I have 10.
Let's see.
Oh, nah, there's nothing I need.
Alright.
Save game.
I can't believe it.
We met Bird Jesus.
Jesus, I can't believe it.
What an honor.
What a fucking honor.
Holy shit.
That's crazy.
He came back to life in front of all of us.
It was a miracle.
Which way?
This way?
No, it was like within here.
A fucking miracle!
Yeah, I can sell it here.
emerald here all right hello i'm back so the scratch emerald
here you yay i look i'm selling his own fucking emerald back
to him like i sold it back to him but you shot him that's
what the media wants that's fake news that's fucking fake
news i can't believe you got brainwashed by the media.
I would never, I would never shoot bird Jesus.
It's not something Doki would do.
Whoop.
Hey, some more money.
Money.
Alright, deceit by fake news.
How could you guys believe in those things?
Tisk, tisk, tisk.
I thought I taught you guys better.
up we go oh my god there is a lot of loot here what the fuck
whose statue is that that's him bird versus bird pilots it's
not unyielding mr kennedy however i'm afraid it ends here
expel this intruder it's the guy don't worry i've got my
pistol right here it's fine it's fine i can just stay here i
don't have to move i'm not scared look at that if i stay
here like they'll just i don't have to move watch this is a
no move run no move run right here reloading first
more i see you wait i see you what the what okay wait wait i
see you wait wait where is he oh i see you that's fucking
right i don't have okay i moved doesn't count i'm
technically still in the same spot chat is that it is that
it that was fast is there no more come down come down
cowards oh my god they're gonna make me walk all the way to
them now that's fucked up how could they do this to me oh
there's loot though all right they don't come over to me
that's not my fault how can i do the no move run if they
don't move either like how does no move run work if they
don't move.
Alright, nice.
Let's see.
I'm just gonna shoot their toes.
What the fuck?
Here we go.
Let me grab that barrel.
And then any other loot here?
That should be it.
Wait!
There's a mini guy.
Nice.
Alright.
There we go.
Up we go.
Where are they?
Hello?
And monks?
Cult followers?
I hear you whispering.
Oh, there you are.
Nice.
That's all...
No, that's not a crit.
There you go.
I mean, it's not so bad being a fucking cult member.
Like, look at that.
Like, if I can tank, like, I'll never be afraid of dying.
Like, think about it.
afraid of dying because you can just tank like six headshots
wow what the fuck what the fuck oh he burned too okay okay
at least at least like he was helping me he was helping okay
if you think about it the flamethrower was helping me
Okay, maybe I can just stay here.
Oh, I can stay here.
Yeah, I'll be fine.
If I don't move, they'll just burn this guys.
I just don't have to move.
What the fuck?
I don't even see this guy.
Alright.
Come on.
There's no way he's fast.
Oh, he's faster.
There you go.
Give me a sec.
I just want to make sure that he's dead.
Before I do anything.
Come on.
What?
There we go.
Alright, here we go.
I'm ready.
What?
Easy.
Fucking easy.
Oh, shit!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Okay, kick kick kick kick kick this was important Okay, kick
wait what what the fuck is that?
Oh shit
Where is that coming from?
No, that's a fire Where is it coming from is it gonna come
towards me?
Oh, it's gone.
Okay, it's fine.
We're fine we're fine see nothing to worry about it's just
one right oh it is not just one it's it's not just one spiky
ball why is there multiple spiky balls no oh thank God okay
okay thank God I thought there was like more to worry about
Get me in the hole!
Okay, I'm in the hole.
Alright, it's fine.
Nothing to worry about.
I'm in the hole.
Alright.
Oh, I can eat my fish now!
Um...
A slightly large bread as an eating fish.
Okay, I need to eat the fish.
I need to eat the fish.
Okay, when is the next ball coming over?
Is that it?
There's no more balls?
Okay.
okay we gotta wait for this ball to drop out all right nice
nice now i'll run this other okay yeah i can fucking bitch
bitch what okay okay i i don't know i for i thought like you
know i don't know i thought he would just let me stab him i
didn't realize he's just gonna to watch me.
Like, how was I supposed to know he was just gonna grab me?
He stood still.
I thought I was safe because he stood still.
Wait, didn't even get up?
No, they can't.
Where are they gonna go?
They can't even... What?
How are they gonna get to me?
Oh!
Oh, he they...
Oh, they're walking to me!
Oh, okay.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
He has to drop down, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, there we go.
Alright, free loot.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
That's someone changing!
It's okay.
They're not good.
They don't know how to fall down.
Reload.
No, we're gonna hoard our grenades until the next game,
chat.
You know the drill.
We're all gonna hoard.
We're gonna hoard until Resident Evil 5.
It's not wasting ammo!
talking about.
Can I, like, shoot this and grab it here?
Yeah, I can.
Wait, I can.
That's so nice.
Alright, that's good.
I can just grab it like that.
Wait, there is a treasure here somewhere.
Where is it?
Where's the treasure?
Huh?
Where the fuck?
Oh, it's right here!
How do we get there?
Oh, wait.
It's above me.
It's It's not a waste, chat.
It's not a waste.
Nice herb.
Because wasting grenades is a bigger waste.
Think about it.
Alright.
F.
Wait, there is more stuff here.
Oh, I'm gonna go up.
Where?
Oh shit there!
I can't see!
Okay, we're gonna shoot it here.
Oh god, oh god, oh god.
There we go, we got him.
Where is he?
Who's fucking...
Who's fucking screaming at me?
me okay oh no my accuracy my 87 accuracy oh there he is oh
god does that hit him
This is so bullshit.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Where did you come from?
Oh god.
God.
Get out.
Get out!
Is he dead?
He must be dead.
Oh shit, where did you come from?
Okay.
Dodged.
Chink.
Kick you out of here.
You know what?
Shake, shake, shake, shake, shake There we go You know what?
I don't even need a waste Oh shit, you know what?
Fuck this Shake, shake, shake, shake It's fine It's fine We
don't, it's fine Just stab!
Just stab!
There you go.
I told you it's fine We don't need guns in this house.
Anything can be a weapon.
Okay, I need a fucking craft shotgun ammo.
Stabbing will always work!
Alright.
How did I waste ammo?
Ow!
Just keep stabbing.
Whoa.
Fuck.
Alright.
What's this?
At the entrance?
Is that it?
You say I can land my egg throw here?
Bro, I'm gonna miss...
I know I'm gonna miss the throw.
It's gonna be like so fucking sad.
Recycle.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hello, Toki.
It's been a busy week for me.
That can only be a VOD game.
But I finally chase all the VODs I can watch you live.
Yeah!
Thank you, Super Chat.
Chat, thank you, thank you.
It's okay.
You're gonna watch me finish this game today.
Uh, this way.
Bump.
Oh.
Okay, we don't look down.
We'll be fine.
Bump!
Guys, we weren't fine.
Okay.
Guys, guys, we were not fine.
Guys, I looked down.
Okay.
Okay, we don't run.
Now we know.
How the fuck was I supposed to know?
Okay, we walk.
We walk.
We're walking now.
We've learned our lesson.
Jesus Christ.
Here we go.
We learn our lesson.
We walk.
And then we grab this too.
Yay!
Oh, okay.
We walk.
We walk so we don't die.
Wait, what?
You're still alive?
Are you still alive?
Oh, hey.
Hello.
Alright, nice.
Oh, thank god you have yellow herbs.
Oh, we can actually make shit.
Alright.
Ania sell.
Um.
This, and then...
Oh, shit, nope.
And then...
Wait, actually, we can...
Let's just combine this for now.
I have a red and also a red.
That's double, right?
Yeah, times two.
1.2.
Yeah, the double reds.
Alright.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Boop!
Uh, tune up!
Okay, right.
repair our knives because we've been fucking around too much
with that.
We've been messing around with that a bit too much.
Alright, let's see.
We have to repair.
You know what?
Let us power up our knife.
And we'll upgrade our...
We'll upgrade our shotgun, actually.
Animal capacity.
There you go.
Save.
all right fine it's fine up we go i don't think i have
enough to max the knife yet i'm like so poor i'm pretty sure
do i have enough to upgrade the knife let me double check so
oh no tune no tune up uh oh i can i can full upgrade it
increase attack.
Guys, okay, but like, do I need to?
Guys, I already saved up for this.
I'm going to save up for the Magnum.
I feel like I'm going to save up for the Magnum because I
feel like I'm not going to, I'm going to use that more in
the end because I missed the box up here.
How could I miss a chest?
Yeah, what do you fucking mean?
I got everything.
What do you mean?
thing there's no painted yellow oh nothing about the fine
that thing's painted yellow believe in the power of the
shank yeah i'm saving it i'm saving up for the boss fights
that's why i don't use it it's all about the boss fight chat
it's about the boss fight i'm investing for term and so I
have delivered the girl to you as promised do tell our Lord
do not forget the loyalty of his servant Ramon oh shit don't
worry I have a fucking egg such a fool mr.
Kennedy to have been bestowed with lures sadly you talk too
much failed shoot the head leon oh i told you shoot the head
that should have been your first shot leon oh man that's not
a bad thing down there surely it's nothing dangerous
I'm being granted by my mask.
Egg and then magma.
If you miss.
I'm gonna miss.
Okay.
This is it.
Ah!
I missed.
I missed!
I told you I told you I need a practice egg but nobody
believed me nobody believed me when I said I needed a
practice egg
None of you thought I needed a prize
Why did no one ever believe me?
Anything is possible
You know anything was possible I can miss What would others
think of you?
I can't believe it.
I'm not redoing it too late.
We have to accept our consequences.
Guys, we have to accept our mistakes, chat.
We can't just reload it whenever we want.
It's not.
We can't just boulders gate this.
I can't believe I missed.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe I fucking missed.
Oh my god.
I can't believe.
I fucking missed the egg.
How?
How did that happen?
look this is a group effort chat this is a group effort i
you didn't give me enough information
i can't believe it you could have given me more information
it's not my fault i was going in there with a lack of info
the lack of intel chat this is a group effort chat we both
fucked up together we fucked up together chat all right here
we go it's fine we're okay no time to lose since when was
this a group effort the contract is subscribing All right,
so thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right, let's see.
We gotta figure this out now.
Okay.
Okay, we're gonna put this here.
And then here we go.
All right, nice.
We have another kitchen knife.
Wait, no, no, the contract is watching the stream, chat.
That's the contract.
By being here, you've signed.
Okay.
Let's see.
We're fine.
It's fine.
We killed him.
Lord Corrosus, hit the target five feet away from you.
Instructions unclear.
Mistake.
You guys could have told me.
To get closer.
I didn't know it was 5 feet.
I was 6 feet away.
Chat.
You guys should have said 5 feet.
I would have walked them up a little bit.
And that is why.
This is a group mistake.
I was lacking information.
To walk closer up.
To get closer.
And because of that.
No, no, no.
If you told me it was.
Within five feet, I would have walked closer.
I was within six feet.
I was six feet away.
I was six feet away, chat.
I did not count for the wind, the wind, you know.
I also did not account for the wind.
So, like, how was I supposed to know the wind was going to
change the trajectory of my egg?
And then there's the weight of the golden egg as well.
You know, golden egg is heavier than a normal egg.
and the boss should have been painted yellow I have failed
you my lord I was unable to fulfill your final commandment
and keep the boy from the path of wickedness I caught a
glimpse of master Ramon's evil temperament during his
younger years when he discovered a servant mocked him by
othering othering whatever the fuck this is behind his back
he summoned her to his private kneel before him.
Ramon dosed her face with viral overt vitriol he pulled out
of his pocket.
The young master watched with glee when the servant writhed
in agony as the skin melted from her face.
His twisted grim still haunts my dreams this very day.
As time passed, Ramon's treachery only deepened and the
infernal cult soon learned they could prey upon his
vulnerable heart.
They manipulated Master Ramon and turned him into their
puppet.
Worst of all, they managed to use him to unleash the Las
Plagas that the Salazar family has fought so long and hard
to keep sealed away.
Lord Diego, rest assured, I intend to watch over Ramon's
until the Master Ramon, until the very end.
Whatever fate may befall us, as a faithful servant of the
Salazar family since birth, is my duty and my power.
penance to you.
All right.
Pretty sure that housekeeper is dead.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Sounds like grade S copium.
Look, it is not my fault that the that the fucking gold egg
is heavier than a normal egg, chat.
That is not my fault.
How was I supposed to know that the gold egg was heavier and
thus changes the grip of my egg?
So Like I ended up throwing it too, too, I ended up throwing
it too light.
I didn't compensate my strength to throw a golden egg.
I didn't account.
I didn't figure out, I couldn't figure out the math in my
head.
I used like normal egg in my head.
He's dead.
He's dead!
Yeah, I'm looking for the key.
Yeah, I did it.
I think this has to be my worst thing.
10% of that was from the egg throw.
That's where the egg was.
Alright, nice.
One end.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We're not responsible for final calculations of the
employer.
Only the first estimate.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But I don't think I'll get a straight answer.
Yeah, she doesn't care about you.
She's only here for the money.
You know, after the incident, the world changed.
Maybe you used word grenades.
You would have more experience with the weight of a metal
agent.
object you haven't changed you just think you have so
here's my question Chris thank you for the super chatting
thank you you'll never be able to punch rocks with a wimpy
throwing arm like that what do you think this is why I don't
punch rocks I kick them we're here not see those thighs If I
could have kicked the egg, I would have made it.
She called me handsome.
Oh my god, new girlfriend right there.
Story of my life.
Guys, it's because I didn't kick the egg.
That was my problem.
If I could have kicked the egg, I would have hit it.
I would have hit the target.
new old girlfriend that was the issue
wait is that machine gun
Ashley there you are
okay that's a lot of machine guns can I okay this is a lot
of machine guns okay can I just snip them from here yeah I
can right
what the Fuck did that man live through that?
Alright, nice.
Well, I got this guy out.
I knew I should have had a second...
I knew I should have had a third egg.
I knew...
I fucking knew I needed a third egg.
I knew it.
You guys were like, no, you just need one egg.
And I was like, no way.
Can I, like, just destroy it?
I can't shoot it!
How the fuck do I get out?
How the fuck do I not die from this?
I just have to walk the other way.
I can't believe it.
I can't just shoot things.
This is so fucked up.
I can't just shoot it.
What's the point if I can't just shoot it?
Oh, it's a merchant!
Alright, is there anything else?
Oh, I need that, actually.
Good thing I saved up.
That's good I saved up there.
Okay, anything new?
The killer.
My pistol is still the best pistol, right?
64.
Okay, we need the case.
And...
Yeah, I think that's all we need.
Let's see.
Okay.
Killer 7's the Magnum?
Okay, I can't afford it, though.
Oh, I can sell this now.
Okay, nice.
And I can sell this, too.
Alright, bye.
We're about to case upgrade.
Okay.
Do I have junk?
Oh, I do.
I have, like, ammo I don't need.
Uh, flash grenade, first aid.
Okay, never mind.
I don't.
Everything is useful.
So, Ashley.
I don't even have Ashley anymore.
There's treasure here.
That's nice.
Treasure.
Treasure time.
Boop.
Nice.
Okay, can I...
Where is it?
The fuck's the treasure?
Where the fuck's the treasure?
I'm looking up.
Is it down?
Where the fuck's the treasure?
Hello?
Oh, it's here!
How do I look at that?
Oh my god, do not throw the name.
Do not throw the name.
How the fuck do I...
What?
How did I read that?
what the fuck oh it's for later oh okay where's that fuck is
that treasure tries throwing the egg
not everything needs to be egged
will it be fine if i just kill him here there you go
he is i can just whoa he got back up that's fine it's fine i
can literally just stay here they just come to me oh my god
okay they're all they're all insect heads just hang him just
this is it this is your chance of practice throwing i don't
need practice to throw i do it every day oh what Now they
know
I...
Guys, you're trying to tell me I was supposed to do this
stealthily?
There's no way.
There's no way this was supposed to be done stealth-wise.
This is it!
There's no way I was supposed to do this stealthily!
would have thought.
Who would have thought?
Chat.
This is where all the new days are for.
This is it, guys.
I told you it was useful.
It was useful.
I knew it.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
Can I just kill him from here?
Here we go.
It's fine.
I can kill him from here.
Oh, he's dead.
That was it.
That's it.
See?
Look, I didn't waste any ammo.
Look at that.
I told you!
See?
Look at that!
I knew that egg throw... That egg throw made me better at
egging people.
I like to think throwing those eggs may be better at
throwing grenades that was the practice that was what was
for practice i am so fucked oh thank god okay are you still
there's still people
there you go there you can burn he's not burning what the
fuck oh there it is all right here you go whoop there you go
whoop that's another 10% gone there see easy it's okay it's
it's like it's handgun ammo we're fine it's handgun ammo
we'll be fine we don't have to worry about handgun ammo chat
we're so healthy we're so fucking healthy all right let's
see i'm gonna go this way i think i killed everybody i think
everybody's just dead whoop i just kill everybody nice hey
how the fuck how do i get over there Did I disable it
already?
I can't tell!
See, look, I got back some handgun ammo.
It's like I didn't waste them.
It's like I never wasted it at all.
Can I get through here?
I can't tell if it's scanning me or not.
Man, that would have been nice to shoot at.
Oh, wait, there's a treasure behind me.
Where's this treasure?
It's like right here?
Oh, here it is.
See, if I didn't kill everybody, I wouldn't have been able
to loot freely, chat.
Look at that.
Now I can loot as much as I want.
See?
This had to be done.
I want to be able to do all this looting.
Why is this yellow?
Oh, that was originally...
It's just... Actually was supposed to be yellow.
Alright, is there anything up here?
Oh, ammo.
Look at that.
Never punished.
I got ammo right here.
Never punished at all.
Okay, it's like this way.
Of course I'm right.
Oh yeah.
The dokiway.
I told you.
The dokiway is always the right way.
Now where am I?
We're on the island.
Okay.
How do I get across from this?
I have to go from here.
Oh my god.
No.
Not from here.
I'm getting lost.
How do I get lost?
How?
How do I...
How do I walk from there?
To go all the way back?
Like this?
Oh, okay, here we go.
Sorry, I had to use my brain for once.
I can't shoot my way out of this.
God damn it.
I actually had to think.
Oh, the misery.
I can't believe it.
I can't just shoot my way out of everything.
So sad.
Not.
How could you say that?
Everything can be shooting if I try hard enough.
I can't believe you would say such a thing.
Okay, let's see.
Whoa!
Let's see.
The fuck how did you hear me?
It can't be my gun, right?
No, not this guy.
Make sure he doesn't get close to me.
Oh, reloading.
Don't get close to me.
Okay, I'm going to use this.
That I heard is a one-shot, so I don't want to risk that.
I'm not risking the one-shot guy.
Oh, he has a helmet.
I can still shoot you in the face.
Okay.
I can tell when you're dead because you fall down.
And you drop loot.
Damon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Is there anybody above me before I go up?
Here's somebody up top.
I had to say this at least once.
You're amazing.
Don't ever change.
Thank you.
I know I'm perfect.
The dokey way.
I could sneak up.
But then I could do this.
Oh!
The rain covered my running.
Rabs, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's what I called a pro gamer.
Exactly.
This is how gamers play this game.
Where are they?
I hear them.
Oh, there he is.
Oh, shit, crit!
Nice.
Good crit.
I know there's, like, one more.
Somewhere.
Where is this?
Holy shit, what the fuck is this map?
I like...
What the fuck he just stood there.
What are you doing in this corner?
Bro, it wasn't even like a hiding spot.
You just stood there.
He wasn't even hiding.
That's like the worst part.
He just stood there.
Like honestly.
What was the point?
He's just chilling.
Okay, let's see.
Oh, we can combine it.
All right, here we go.
He's missing.
Toki, he was trying to use the bathroom.
Does it look like there's any toilets here?
But why in the cave?
Like, help the bushes grow or some shit.
Like, I don't know.
Like, why waste the liquid on the rock?
Let me shoot the legs.
Wait, what the fuck?
Shoot the toes.
Alright, here we go.
I'll shoot the legs here.
It's five.
Shoot the leg.
Nice.
Wait, what?
Behind me?
Oh, wait, no, it's him.
Alright, there you go.
Just gotta make sure.
He's a fan of you.
Really shit It's he's trying to he's trying to make some
diamonds you don't understand A rocket launcher a rocket
launcher What the fuck Yeah, this is not good at all Wait,
where is the rocket launcher guy?
Oh, there he is Oh shit.
Okay Okay, we're gonna make sure I'm gonna shoot you in the
legs all right there you go all right kick time kick time
kick oh what the fuck my god you should go into pro
wrestling oh god here you go here we go i shank him oh he
was dead he was dead anyway i can't tell when you're dead
Thank you for pausing.
Alright, nice.
Thank god he paused.
Thank you for pausing.
What?
I'm practicing for sniper elite.
You know, for the ball shot.
Guys, you won't understand.
It's for the ball shot.
There you go.
He really fought.
Nice.
Alright, here we go.
Whoa!
Bro, how come like you get arrows but that one guy gets a
fucking rocket launcher?
Jesus Christ, where did you come from?
Yeah.
The nesticle shot.
We had to practice somewhere, chat.
We needed to find time to practice for it.
This was that time.
budget cuts bro that poor guy
okay just want to make sure there's no loot up here oh okay
and there's never mind what that oh my god that doesn't
count nice crit oh not nice it's okay he needs to take time
to crawl up we're good It was too much time to walk up.
Okay, I was going to say if there's anybody, like, waiting
there because they had to pee.
Pee in the corner there, I was waiting.
Alright, nice.
Yay!
Imagine if I had to stealth all of that.
Would be a waste of my time.
Would have been a huge waste of time.
The P corner, exactly.
Let's see.
Oh my god!
What?
Alright, we gotta do this, apparently.
This is a long area.
Okay, that's a rocket launcher, dude.
I just wanna make sure I killed a rocket launcher dude
first.
Because, like, all these other guys don't matter at that
point.
Okay.
These guys don't matter.
I just have to kill the rocket launcher, man.
Alright, get over here.
Oh.
He shot.
There you go.
Nice.
Alright, are you wearing anything on your helmet?
No, I could totally shoot that.
That's a gas mask.
Gas mask isn't tanky enough to stop a bullet.
Wait, what the fuck you're alive?
Oh shit.
Yeah, he's alive.
all right don't worry we're five we're gonna you see those
three ammo we're gonna grab ammo from that one guy supposed
to go here okay there should be loot here
pistol ammo yay like i never waste a handgun ammo never
punished i love not getting punished
There is a...
Where is it?
I hear it.
What the fuck is it?
Huh?
Where are you?
I hear you.
Oh, right here in this corner.
Okay.
I don't even know why I shoot these.
I already missed one.
There's no point in doing these.
Oh my god.
Um...
I think you're here somewhere.
Are you?
Oh no, this door is here.
Oh.
Hello.
Oop.
Go back, guys.
It's in the village.
I don't think I can go back, guys.
Guys, that's how far I've missed it.
It's all the way back in the fucking village.
it's gone it's so over it's so over you have to move on it's
gone gone reset the run it's the only way where do i go do i
go from do i use this door
can i open this door no right yeah
safe area.
It's above?
Where is that?
Is that the one outside?
I can't tell if it's not the one outside.
We're upstairs.
Maybe they can activate this.
Come on.
Yay!
What the fuck?
He just walked through that!
That's not...
No.
What the fuck?
How's that fair?
You can just walk through that?
How did he survive?
Bro!
That's fucked up.
That's so unfair.
Who said he just Taked it?
He still had the worst part Is that he still has his legs
Like I look look see okay Someone's going barefoot He still
has his legs Did I miss anything?
No Boop Oh yeah I've done the suplex Lea's definitely Like
those legs are definitely wrestling material
Oh wait the lockers I almost forgot about the lockers.
Okay, nice.
Nice.
Is there any other lockers back here?
No, it's just those.
Alright.
Yeah, those were all the lockers.
I can't believe it.
That's so not fair.
It was so fucking thick.
Alright.
Gotta save on my typewriter.
Here we go.
Yeah, no yellow paint.
I How is I supposed to know if there's loot?
If there's no yellow paint on the locker.
Ashley!
Shit!
Just wake up!
Are you stupid?
Why don't you just wake up?
Rescue Ashley.
Where are the thing?
My god, it doesn't seem.
It's fine.
I'll just kill him before he comes over.
That's fine.
Oh, this is not fine.
Oh my god, this is not fine.
It's okay Yes, okay, it's fine.
See, it's fine.
Who needs stealth?
Gun.
Gun is my stealth.
I like how after I used my rifle ammo someone was like save
your rifle ammo
Thank you
Every fucking time Doki This is the right time to save your
rifle ammo Doki I say as I fucking shot four fucking bullets
Doors jammed God damn I don't have Ashley for this Why can't
I just shoot the fucking thing Ashley get up
Okay.
Where the fuck do I go?
Oh, there's a ladder here.
Oh my gosh.
God damn it.
The yellow paint has to be more yellow.
Why couldn't they make the yellow paint more yellow?
Alright.
Don't worry.
I have my rifle right here.
Alright.
Let's see.
I'm gonna put this together.
just in case.
Alright, here we go.
I have my rifle.
Okay, let's kill this guy first.
Nice, crit.
Alright.
Goodbye.
Boop.
Anything else?
Anybody else here?
I hear you.
Come on, get closer.
I can't shoot you in the...
legs i can't shoot you in the kneecaps or the balls nice
okay get over here boom shot you in the nuts too just in
case now you'll never have kids nice honestly i'm pretty
sure you can't have kids because of the whole larvae
parasite thing in you i don't think you're able to produce
children I didn't shoot you in the balls.
Let's see this way.
Is there any loot?
Loot!
Money!
Ammo.
I missed ammo?
Oh, I did!
Fuck.
Let me go back.
It's right here.
It's the thing that was glowing.
I missed the glowing thing.
How could I?
It was literally glowing.
You always surprise me, Doki.
Oh.
Don't like this.
Do not like this kitchen.
Locker.
Okay, shotgun ammo.
I sort of need...
I sort of need rifle ammo because I wasted it.
Woo!
Hello?
Anybody in the P corner?
Lord Croesus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Reminder.
Adoption is always an option.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What the fuck?
Why is there like...
I don't like this.
I don't like how there was like a corridor for no reason.
Because that means there is a reason.
Hello?
Oh, hey.
Money.
I don't like that.
Oh!
Okay.
Just in case.
Don't even drop loot?
What the fuck?
Bro!
Oh, merchant.
I'm safe.
Oh, is there anything I can sell?
Okay, sell.
Sell.
Okay, do I have it, love?
One, two, three, four, five.
I do fuck yeah okay I'm gonna sell I'm gonna make this stuff
first before I sell oh I got another crown I even noticed
all right one two three okay one two nice another 100k easy
uh oh I can make another one nice yeah there was no way I
was gonna find four of a cop like three of a kind of the
same color.
Alright.
Easy 100k.
Okay, that is...
Oh, that's a lot of money.
Uh, I might as well just upgrade my knife.
And then...
Wait, is it worth it?
Nah.
I might...
i'm gonna upgrade my magnum i already did i maxed out okay
technically it's maxed out because i have the upgrade i'm
gonna i'm gonna do the i'm gonna do the fucking my magnum i
feel like that's much more worth it let's see oh wait we're
gonna have the rifle fight right okay uh reload speed ammo
rate of fire uh Let's see.
I guess maybe like more reload, I feel like.
Reload speed.
A well-tuned weapon can make up for a lack of speed.
Yeah, I'll do readify.
And then I'll max out.
Actually, I can max it out.
I have enough money to max this out.
Yay!
Don't get yourself killed now.
All right.
All right, my rifle is beefed up.
My fucking rifle is so fucking beefed up now.
Okay, let's see.
Don't worry.
This is a tanky rifle.
I can even craft more rifle ammo just in case.
Just in case.
And then I say...
Wait, what?
Chicken!
Wait, there's a chicken here?
This is not a good place for a chicken.
Because not...
93 saves.
Here we go.
all right wait i hear it i hear the chicken oh my god there
she is where were you chicken when i needed you i don't like
this all right here you go wait i don't have the key for
this still i'll have to go this way all right all right why
do i need the rifle we're gonna find out soon I assume we
find out here.
What?
Where do I go?
Freezer?
I'm gonna go to the freezer.
God damn it.
I need cars for everything.
What?
What
was that?
What was that?
what was that guys what was that guys what was that guys
what was that guys what was that guys
guys what was that guys what was that guys what are those
things over there what was that why was he crying i'm gonna
use the bathroom of your back
Oh, why is it in the dark?
Why?
Oh, my God.
Wait.
The exit break.
Oh, no.
Guys, oh, thank God.
I thought I accidentally broke my mouth.
Oh, my God.
Oh.
Why is it even dark?
My God.
I hate
this.
Okay.
Your key card application has been approved by the head of
the department.
Please bring your level 1 key card to dissection and follow
the procedure on the next page.
Overwrite card for level 2 clearance using the machine
located in freezer.
Overwrite card for level 3 clearance using the machine
located in incubation lab.
Please ask each section supervisor for machines to access
the permission to access the machines.
I didn't even finish reading the lore.
I was so scared.
Oh wait, I did.
Oh my god!
What did I open?
I don't even know what I opened.
I'm too scared.
I...
I can't, man!
Oh my god!
I hate this!
Oh my god, it is dark!
It's dark!
Holy fuck, okay.
Where do I go?
I hate this.
I hate this so much.
I hate this so fucking much.
I hate this.
I don't even have the key card!
What do I- Oh my god, bro, I'm struggling.
out i'm so stressed out where do i go do i go here is it
here oh my god
dissection where is dissection
Oh my god there, okay Oh my god, I hate this, I hate this, I
hate this so fucking much Oh my god
What?
Oh, oh my god, please Okay
Where does it need to go?
Oh, there!
Okay.
I'm so confused.
Oh, okay.
Okay, I can figure this out, guys.
I did it.
I did it, guys.
What the fuck is that?
What kind of experiments are they doing here?
What the fuck was that?
At last, I created a new life.
I call it regenerator.
This metabolic capacity is incredible.
Unless all the parasite residing with it are destroyed, the
tissue can...
Wait, can they never die?
They never die?
I can't kill it!
Oh, yeah.
upon examining the body with a biosensor
a look from that the parasites behave like vital organs for
the host almost as though it has multiple harm the new
creation mind is essentially immortal surely even dr
Frankenstein himself would want to shake my hand in
admiration oh no I'll be fine if there were lights.
There's no lights.
The new creation of mine is essentially...
These guys made me put down the game for three days in the
OG while I was playing in the dark.
Thank you for the super chat, Cass.
Thank you.
This new creation of mine is essentially immortal.
even darker to her and concern myself i want to shake my
hand i share the news of my achievements with what
pretentious bastard colleague of mine his face went white
then he started scribbling something in his notebook i
thought he'd be impressed but instead he actually had the
nerve to warn me of the so-called dangers it's a full of
everything under control
The subject went wild and scraped from its cryogenic tank.
I was the real fool.
Guys, where's the scope?
Guys, where the fuck is the scope?
Guys.
Where's the scope?
Guys, where's the scope?
Leave me alone.
Oh
My God, okay, okay, okay guys, where's the skull?
Where is these skulls?
Where's the
power?
Where's the power?
Guys guys Where's the power?
Where do I go?
Here!
Do I go here?
Is it this?
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay,
okay.
Boom.
Oh, God.
Oh my god, get out, get out, get out, get out, it was at
this moment, she knew she fucked up, scope, scope, scope,
scope, scope, scope, scope, okay, surely I have a pause
here, right?
going to insufficient power?
What do you mean?
Guys, he won't attack me, right, guys?
Surely, right?
If I just...
I do it.
He's just spanking.
Nah, he won't attack me while I'm doing this.
There's no way.
There's no way he would attack me while I'm doing this.
Oh my god.
No way.
There's no way.
Oh god.
Where is the power for this?
He's just waiting patiently.
Thank god.
Please keep waiting.
Oh my god.
Is that the scope?
That's not even the scope.
I don't need to.
This!
I don't need this, I need the fucking scope!
Okay, we're fine.
We are so fucking fine.
Oh god.
What's in here?
Is there only one of him or is there multiple?
There's multiple!
Now there's two!
Oh fuck!
No!
Okay, okay, we're fine.
Okay.
okay level two key card do i need to flip the switch guys do
i need to flip the switch guys
i forgot the card hey i'm back
i got the card i got the card you You guys lied!
You guys lied!
It's not done!
It's pro- What the fuck is this bullshit?
It doesn't matter.
Keeping my card.
Oh my god, give me the card.
Give me the card.
okay do i need to reset the power do i need to reset i can't
believe it's still processing thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you collecting immortal monsters like
pokemon cards where's the scope where is this go where is it
here is it the treasure is it the treasure go to door to
where this is door to
Is this door true?
Is this the door?
No.
Okay.
I hate this.
This is hell.
This is actual hell.
I found hell.
I found it.
Oh my god, real people.
This is fine.
Oh my god, I'm so happy to see you.
I'm so happy to see you guys.
Oh my god.
This is fine.
Turn around.
Real people.
Oh, thank god.
What the fuck?
Okay, that was that was my bad.
I actually didn't see you Where the fuck?
Where did he come from?
That guy scared the shit out of me Jeez, oh my god Oh I did
I looked away.
I looked away for one second.
I looked away i was freaking out guys i was freaking out
okay i was freaking out i looked away oh my god oh my god
i'm so sad i'm so sad oh
oh no There they are!
Oh, there's so many of them.
Where do I go?
It's just gonna break out.
It's just gonna...
Oh!
They're just gonna break out, man.
Oh my god.
there's the scope oh my god there it is there's the scope
there it is oh shit there it is do i put it on le5 do i put
it on the the rifle right the sr okay there's the scope
oh very recent power outage a test subject woke from the
stasis broke out of its holding tank and escaped the subject
was contained after 20 hours we were unable to recover one
of the bodies and a tool from inside it the cause of this
unfortunate incident is the unstable power supply the
outdated generators cannot keep up with our demanding
schedule Management must prioritize the needs of the
engineer over those of the researchers to prevent something
like this ever happening again.
Oh my god, they're just looking at me like that.
Oh my god.
Thank god, I hate this.
How do I- Where do I get the wrench?
Where do I get the wrench?
It's inside one of these guys.
It's inside these fuckers.
feel it it's inside these fuckers it's in there oh there it
is i see it do i shoot it i'm gonna shoot it did that do
anything what here we go there we go all right i figured it
out i'm gonna shoot right
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Nice.
Okay, there's the wrench.
There's the wrench.
There it is.
Oh, there it is.
Wrench time.
Oh, wrench time.
Key time.
Oh, thank God.
I'm fine.
I'm fine with, like...
That's fine.
Alright, nice.
I got his leg.
Oh!
That's not fair.
Oh, shit!
Oh, fuck.
There we go.
He has no body now.
He has no body.
He has no body to regenerate!
Okay.
I gotta...
I gotta reload.
There we go!
That hurts me!
Oh!
How is I supposed to know he was that close?
What?
Somebody get up?
No.
Oh!
Okay, reloading.
Reloading.
Oh, reloading.
Woo!
I do not feel comfortable that they're just there.
I don't feel comfortable at all.
Oh my god, this sucks.
This sucks.
This fucking sucks.
It sucks so much!
They still have loot, I don't want to kill them!
Bye, bye.
I'll do it for the loot.
Okay, that's bullshit.
That is bullshit!
That's a hit!
How?
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
Bro, sometimes.
Sometimes I don't understand.
I don't understand.
Like, oh, that's a hit now.
You're shooting through a lot of flesh.
I don't understand.
Why didn't I save more of my...
ammo why I should have saved some ammo I should have saved
more ammo why was this painted yellow with zero loot there's
so many questions oh but the other two I don't care let them
live
okay actually i got the i don't
care i don't care about the gold bar anymore who fucking
cares i don't care i just wanna leave
heal i had an extra one don't worry You can take the vaccine
to eliminate the bugs.
It's like the color of your hair, too.
You're gonna be okay.
Wait, what?
I thought I got healed.
So what were you doing in the cave then?
What was Lewis and I doing in the cave?
Oh, it was only temporary.
Like, what the fuck was the point?
Oh, my God.
I hate, I hate the regenerators so fucking much.
I hate them so much.
They are...
Ashley.
Sorry, I'm late.
You're okay, Ashley.
Thank you.
You brought the medicine just in time.
Can you stand?
Where's Louise?
Good question.
Yes, let me lie to her.
It's not like she's, like, in her 20s and can take a lie.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Edgar, thank you.
Just a temporal relief.
If the bug matures, you need to take other measures.
Oh, yeah, we have to, like, cut it open.
Ada, come in.
There's a lab where we can remove the parasites.
Had a crazy hunch that you'd know where it is.
their most important facilities are holding the shotgun at
the top of the mountain that's where i
okay happy to help now you owe me thank you ada thank you
let me read the lore we're in prison without warning one by
one we are taking to the next room do you not know what
happens there they just took annabelle i'm probably next
i've got to think i need to get my head straight all who are
infected with the Plaga will be at the mercy of Lord Sadler.
If he commands it, they will work themselves to death with a
smile on their face.
Adversely, the host becomes so simple-minded that they're
basically useless for any complex task.
However, we succeeded in developing the new superior species
of Plaga, as no special variability, but the host's
cognitive functions are not diminished.
It seems like they plan to administer this new species to
the girl.
It's clearly important perfection.
All tests were successful and plans for mass production are
moving forward.
The project is a complete success, but I've been imprisoned.
And preparations to inject me the superior species are
underway in the next room.
Annabelle is not herself anymore.
The smile has been completely white from her face.
Writing is the only thing that keeps me sane now.
Not that anyone ever read this.
Wait, does that mean I have the...
do i have the uh uh the uh the superior one or the dumb one
i can't tell with leon i i can't tell um let's see good
question okay i hate this oh my god i hate i hate you
actually I hate you so much.
Okay.
Okay, here we go.
Now I have to deal with the regenerators and you!
I should have kept you in there!
I should have locked you back in.
I have the key card.
I should have just locked you back in.
I literally have the key card to lock her back in.
I...
much a master of unlocking all right oh my god the merchant
is here if anyone has a moment spirit will you please turn
these blue medallions into a broken mess in the floor i know
that won't bring back the old days but i can't let this
stand okay where the are the medallions they're all over
here okay god get me off of this island get me out of here
I don't want to be here anymore.
Oh, there's the barrel.
Alright.
Let's see.
Yeah, I need some new shit.
Anything new?
What do you have for me that's new?
There's nothing new, liar!
Bang for you, Buck.
Oh, this is the same thing.
okay okay i need to repair this and i need to repair my
knife and then wrench key card my crystal ore and then
that's it why the fuck do i need to can i sell the ore can i
can i can i sell the ore because i feel like is it for
selling only yeah Okay.
Because it was like...
Because it like made me be like...
It showed me a description for it.
So I couldn't tell.
Oh, I can sell the SMG.
Alright.
I'm going to sell the SMG.
Fuck this.
The LE-5.
This one, right?
Is this the SMG?
Yeah, the cell machine gun.
Yeah, I'm going to sell the ammo for this too.
Okay.
Nice.
I'll sell the SMG.
uh it's already mp5 do i have an mp5 no i don't i was like
i'm pretty sure i don't
oh hell all right do i have enough to upgrade yet will that
be up oh no i need a hundred thousand
oh okay here we go ah
Stay close, Ashley.
No, I need you to stay close.
Stay close.
Alright, we're outside.
I like outside.
Outside, good!
Thank you.
Wait, what?
What's that sound?
Look, I needed that money.
Guys.
Wait, I hear something.
but like where there's like there's like loot somewhere here
but where how the fuck do I where is this loot I'm looking
up where is it
oh my god it's right here oh my god alright shooting time
shooting time hello oh my god where the fuck is the enemy I
hear them
god I hear them I swear to god if you're in the p corner
okay there they are how okay just wait here Ashley
just wait here that's It's fine.
We don't need to get closer.
Ashley, you're a detriment.
I'm worried about the...
I'm worried about them fucking showing up because of their
P-corner.
It's like right here.
What the fuck is this?
Where is it?
There's like a loot thing here somewhere.
I swear to God, I swear to God if you're here.
I swear.
I got.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Ashley, why?
Why are you still with me?
I missed the fucking medallion.
I can search trash cans?
What?
Oh my god.
I can.
Wait, there is.
Wait, there was a...
Oh, there it is.
There, yeah, I got it.
Awesome.
Oh my god, now I can search...
Oh wait, there's ammo.
I'm sorry, Ashley.
This is important, Ashley.
I am a loot goblin, and I need to obtain the ammo.
Oh, yeah, there was one here, too, anyway.
What the fuck?
There we go.
Where the fuck is that ammo?
How did I miss it again?
Okay, thank god I, like, turn around.
Where's the ammo?
Oh, it's here.
It was right in front of me this entire time.
God damn it.
Hello?
There we go.
Crit.
I love me, my crits.
Nice.
Oh, what?
What?
Okay.
I could have just done that.
Oh well.
I might have saved a lot.
I might have saved three bullets if I just walked to the
side.
If only I just walked to the side.
Alright, five.
We did it.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, we don't need the money.
Do we need the money?
Ashley, are we that poor?
Do we need that money?
Can you find it?
Oh my god, maybe we don't.
I don't want to find this.
Oh my god, it's in front of me!
Okay, we're fine.
This island is actually driving me insane.
I fucking hate this island.
There's so much right now.
Okay.
This island is driving me crazy.
I'm just gonna shoot the legs.
Oh, wait, what the fuck?
Okay.
You know what?
Oh, fuck this, man.
Present for you.
Ew, yo.
What?
How do you survive a grenade?
Oh!
You're serious.
Here you go.
There's no way.
wise actually i swear i hope i did not actually oh nice he
shot him his own teammate that's good all right stab nice
money all right fox you okay oh fuck man i don't know i
don't know on one hand having ashley here makes me less
scared.
On the other hand, having Ashley here means she is more
likely to die by the regenerators.
I don't know, Ashley.
I'm less scared, but also you are going to be such a pain.
You're going to feel such a pain later.
Holy shit.
Alright, here we go.
I could just feel I could just feel it I could feel myself
missing every possible shot while you die wait what oh
actually go do this thing actually actually open that door
for me
nice oh no am i by myself here now
Am I?
Wait, there's a loot here.
Which way?
Which way do I go?
Am I going the right way?
Oh, there it is.
Wait, what?
Already?
How?
Ashley, where are you?
I left you friends!
I left you for 30 seconds, Ashley.
Be careful.
I left you for 30 fucking seconds.
Holy fuck, really?
Really?
Fucking really?
Oh my god, I can't believe it, Ashley.
Like...
30 fucking seconds.
And you're dead.
You alright?
No, mentally, no.
Absolutely not.
Absolutely not, Ashley.
I am not okay.
Oh my god.
I have to do this again.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
Where did she go after?
Ashley.
No problem.
Alright.
Where are this suit?
Ashley.
Oh, damn it.
Where do they go?
Hang in there.
Do I actually kill?
Okay, I don't kill her.
I was gonna say, what if I accidentally kill her there?
The point blank shotgun shot.
I was like, that is the risk I'm willing to take, Ashley.
Ashley.
I was willing to take that risk
Thank fucking God Thank God you live Problem solved I knew I
knew I wouldn't hit her Guys I just knew I knew that like
she would live Ashley, why are you... Ashley, stop!
Bro!
Ashley, stop!
You're fucking freaking me out!
She can't... I couldn't see!
Ashley!
Oh my god.
I don't... I can't.
I really can't be bothered.
Here we go.
here we go.
Yeah, he bothers.
Oh, my God.
Holy shit, I don't miss you.
I do not miss you at all.
Don't leave me.
Where did you go?
Where did she go?
Oh, What?
How?!
Ashley!
Stop!
Where are you?
Jesus Christ!
Holy fuck.
Holy fucking shit.
I can't.
I can't with this girl.
I actually cannot.
Please get in a fucking locker somewhere.
Like, I swear to go- just fucking get in a locker somewhere.
Oh my god.
Smells pretty bad.
She needs a lot.
Yeah, I can tell.
I can tell.
There is loot somewhere here.
Actually, why are you clipping?
Why are you clipping everywhere?
Please, you are driving me insane right now.
We go at the same time.
Yeah Got it.
All right, here we go.
Here we go.
We go at the same time.
Yeah, okay.
Oh, it's okay We got this.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Sorry.
I couldn't understand.
I know I gave the instruction But like I couldn't understand
what they mean.
I I couldn't I was like, I know you said we go at the same.
Oh my go in go in live in here Live in here!
Just live in here.
It's regenerator time.
I assume this is where I do regenerator shit.
It's time.
That's fine.
As long as I don't have to deal with you.
Oh my god.
Stay there forever.
Just stay there.
Yeah.
Yep, there it is.
Yep.
There it is.
Oh my god.
I fucking knew it.
What?
You stubborn son of a bitch.
I'm shooting the head!
Oh!
I swear, I swear I'm shooting the head.
okay there we go
oh he's wiggly oh my god you're not hurt are you oh thank
god okay oh you got it no say say it actually stay there
actually actually please stay in the locker actually please
Did I fuck up?
Whoops.
What button do I press?
I thought...
What button F is it F?
Is it F?
Okay.
I...
One more time.
I can't.
I fucking can't.
What?
Why?
I pressed it!
I swear.
Oh my god.
There's like a delay.
I swear.
There is a delay, guys.
I swear to God there's a delay.
I swear.
Chat, I didn't do that on purpose.
There's a fucking delay.
I swear.
I didn't do that on purpose.
There's like a three second delay.
No.
Oh, not the power!
Oh my god.
Get this for me.
Okay.
Leave it to me.
I'm actually pretty good at this stuff.
Oh.
I swear to God, chat.
I swear to God there was a delay.
Boop.
Oh my god.
I hate this so much.
God, if that's just a rat.
It's just a rat.
Just a fucking rat.
Run.
Run where?
Where do I- guys.
I just saw someone said, as soon as I turned that power,
just run.
Where do I run?
You can't just say run.
Just run.
Do I run back?
Do I run forward?
Where?
Where is that running?
I'm still arriving.
Thank you for the yakuza.
Thank you.
Okay.
Run.
Where is the power?
Oh
Where is it?
I
go the wrong way Oh, there's stuff here There's fish and
then there's herbs
All right, here we go Apparently I gotta start running
Oh my god, I'm running I'm running actually where are you?
Ashley.
Ashley, damn it.
Where did you go, Ashley?
Ashley?
Ashley!
What the fuck?
What the?
What was that?
Actually, what the fuck?
Ashley, fuck?
What?
What was that?
What the fuck was that?
Ashley!
How do you think this?
Oh.
There.
Okay.
Okay, oh shit!
Oh my god!
You keep coming.
Thanks.
I can't believe I saw that.
I can't believe my dad's like sucking...
I can't believe that was real.
I can't believe that was real!
Doki plus fear equals alluding to his episode.
grossest thank you for the super chat thank you thank you oh
my god i literally just saw her i okay the worst part was
that i saw her i'm not fucking going back for that loot i
don't care enough for this i thought she just they just
stood there behind her until i crossed the Fucking rich.
I can't believe that like that was so bullshit.
Oh my god That was actually the most fucking ridiculous shit
I've ever I just can't Like how is that real?
How is that fucking real?
That does not feel good real I'm not going I do not care
enough for this what the fuck bro what the bro What is...
What?
Okay.
Let's go.
What the fuck is he doing?
Okay, here we go.
Let's go.
Let's go, Ashley.
Yes, I did.
Okay, there we go.
The rats.
Sterminate all the rats in the waste disposal.
Will someone help me keep things clean and take care of
those tiny critters?
But which here?
Disposal?
God, I don't want to...
I don't want to go back.
I don't care.
This is going to be...
Oh, my God.
I don't want to go back.
All right.
This makes or breaks if I go back to do the rats.
Will there be anybody else trying to kill me?
Guys, if I go back, are there going to be enemies there?
This will make or break it.
Oh my god.
Holy shit, pro.
Pro.
Ashley, like, ages me here.
Okay, one.
Okay, I need two.
Okay, one, two.
And then I need a yellow.
Wait, I should know I can do this.
Wait, I can!
Okay, I can do it.
Okay, here we go.
I need to put that here.
And then I'll put that here.
Okay, that should be.
Oh!
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
Sell.
Gold.
Necklace.
Boop.
I think I have...
Wait, I have enough for the upgrade.
Yeah, okay, nice.
Oh, grab the upgrade for the rifle.
Oh, all right, save.
All right, I'm going to use the bathroom before we walk
through the rats.
I'll be right back.
I hate Ashley so much.
Affiliate, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I've never hated a game character this much before.
I've never hated A video game character As much as I've
hated Ashley Oh my god Is Ashley crazy I don't care
Oh my god oh my god all right here we go there any i hear a
rat i hear you okay oh i knew you were there i'm gonna save
because i don't want to shoot that rat again which one is
worse og ashley or a new the thing is i've never got this
far in og ashley og ashley i got to the part where where we
had to escort like where we played her solo level that was
as far as we got the og ashley so like i don't know they're
both terrible they're both absolutely terrible
oh my god
okay i need to know guys i need to know where are the other
two rats Where the fuck are the other two rats?
Where is the two rats?
Oh my god.
I don't know where the other rats are!
I got the boxes, though.
Oh my god, there's one of them.
I hate you.
I hate you so much.
Where's the last rat?
Where the fuck?
I'm...
I'm not getting the fish.
Oh, where the fuck is the last rat?
Nothing.
Oh my god, you thought you could hide.
You thought you could hide.
I fucking see you.
Jesus Christ, I see you.
They heard the gunfire and cheese it.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Let's go.
Let's go, Ashley.
I'm done.
I'm so done.
Get over here.
I got the request.
Where would it?
What can I do?
I did it.
I fucking did it.
Okay.
Save time.
We're gonna break a hundred, guys.
We're gonna break a hundred.
We're almost there!
Boop!
Alright, where do I go?
I don't like this.
I'm getting my shotgun just in case.
What?
Oh my god.
Fall.
Fall!
I'll never trust again.
I don't- Guys!
Oh my god, why is There's so many fucking fire stuff.
What are you doing?
Ashley, what are you doing?
Is that the lift?
Skizz.
Oh, God.
Oh, here we go.
We're gonna smash.
Smash, smash.
I'm eating my tangerine.
just go smash i don't care anymore you're serious
am i controlling anything no is this what they teach kids in
school these days actually you're not certified
is this what they teach people in private private school
like ultra private school the one for the the one with the
celebrities and the president daughters
Am I supposed to- Oh my god, I'm supposed to fucking protect
her.
Oh my fucking god.
No!
Oh my god.
Of course.
Of course I have to protect her.
Of course I do!
Okay.
Where are the other ones?
ones.
Why are you over here?
There they are.
Oh my god.
No, my 70%!
Oh no.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
It is so fine.
There we go.
I told you it's so fine.
We're so okay.
Alright.
See?
Nothing to worry about.
My fucking crane is still full HP.
Oh, he's just giving me money.
Why is it just money?
Is that it?
Just don't hurt me.
Just don't hurt me, Ashley.
Oh.
Yay.
Ashley no that's what you said last time you said that last
time actually you lied oh come on bro oh
shit my shoulder
Oh, this is bad.
This is bad.
This is so bad.
Oh!
You are screaming!
I'm screaming!
As of this!
Oh my god.
Bro, as they are trying!
Actually, I am going through more than you right now.
Oh, jeez.
Oh, my God.
I'm going through so much shit right now.
Holy shit, thank you.
Thank you for the ammo.
Thank you so much.
Holy fuck.
Give me a craft.
Oh my god, I'm so fucked up right now.
This is fine.
This is so fine.
Get out.
Get the fuck out.
Okay, there must be more animal here.
Oh my god.
Please.
Oh, thank you.
you.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
I dealt with so much today.
I went through so much pain.
All right.
Get out, Ashley.
It's time.
Thank you for the loot.
Thank you so much.
There has been sighting of what appears to be a strange
corpse wandering around.
likely the result of some immortal experiment once someone
put it out of its misery and its and end its pathetic
existence incubation lab are you kidding me isn't that all
the way back here
don't worry guys i'm definitely gonna come back
Don't worry.
We're going to come back.
I think you might have found your calling.
Alright.
Let's see.
I think we got to push this.
Don't worry, guys.
I swear we're going to come back, guys.
See?
I unlocked the shortcut.
That means I'm coming back.
Guys, unlocked the shortcut.
I'm going to come back, guys.
Don't worry.
Don't worry guys don't worry we back
Fun fact you could have spent the process up by throwing
grenades at the wall to weaken it for Ashley So it would
break later that works Well either way snow think of the
super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you have fun all right it's okay we'll come back at uh
part four of the gameplay guys don't worry we'll come guys
in part four of Resident Evil 4 we'll come back chat and
then do this and we get out of here
oh my god I fucking hate her so much.
I must stress the use of extreme caution when handling the
amber deposits from underneath the castle.
Work with the utmost respect and obedience.
It is imperative that you do not disturb the holy body's
slumber.
Okay.
Wait, what?
Not the amber right there?
This must be what Luis was talking about.
Yeah, this is what you were talking about.
This is the deposit.
The rock.
It's the rock!
Let's see.
John Cena's better.
Oh, there's an yellow herb.
I need that.
Uh...
See.
Okay, we just need a red herb.
Okay, I'm just making sure I loot everything.
Anything back here?
What's back here?
Dearest Lord Sadler, I'm overjoyed to report wonderful news.
Production of the superior species of Las Plagas is
officially underway.
If all goes accordingly, rest assured that we'll reach our
ultimate goal.
The Plagas is a truly magnificent organism.
It has the capacity to live in any vertebrate, be it a
human, dog, or even crow.
There are no other parasites like it on Earth.
species is particularly impressive, as it can assimilate
with a host without causing any damage to the brain.
No one can oppose the strength of your dominance, my lord.
On the contrary, whoever resists once experienced an other
joy accompanies the absence of free will.
I am living proof how ignorant I once was.
In a few days, I will have finished administrating the plaga
to all the high-ranking researchers, and then they too shall
know.
And when your plan is complete, the whole world shall know.
Oh, it's Annabelle, the girl that stops smiling.
She's the one that stops smiling.
Alright.
This is it.
Oh, yeah, that's a lot of parasites.
There they are.
That's what's inside you, Ashley.
You're a cross-trained yourself.
This is our holy body.
I wonder if that's Annabelle, the one to the left.
Such a profound blessing for all.
Lost platter.
Welcome.
Oh my god.
He's like...
I am Osmond Sadler.
The speaker for our Lord.
Tell someone who gives a shit.
Oh.
Foolish lambs.
Oh my god, he heals so fast.
Now, abandon your body.
Obey the voice of our Lord.
Oh.
Don't worry, I'll heal just like him.
Do not resist.
actually your aim what have i what the is going on over
there
no ammo pray forgive these wicked sinners my faithful
disciples shall deliver to you your penance now child you
need not be afraid submit your body and release yourself
from fear
Why not me?
Do I have the Dumber one?
Do I have the Dumb Parasite?
I can't tell.
I can't tell if I have the Dumb Parasite or the Smart One.
We got the Leon Parasite.
I like how they just left me.
Like, why don't they just... They could have... He could
have personally killed me.
Like, why did they leave me?
Why don't you, like, personally do it?
Wait, is that the...
What is that?
Oh, that's just the normal one.
Turn around.
Here you go.
wait was that people oh what the fuck ow oh shit wait how is
he gonna come up oh the ladder nice come on come up the
ladder that's fucking right my ladder bitch come on climb up
oh there we go I'm just making sure there's nobody behind me
Come up the ladder.
That's fucking right.
Wait, how do you headshot this?
Oh, no.
Oh,
man.
Come up the ladder.
That's fucking right.
I forgot.
I just need a stab.
I don't have to worry about...
I don't have to worry about fucking shooting him.
He's on the ladder.
all right nice gunpowder per your request redevelopment of
the island is well underway weapons and other defensive
equipment have been set up to guard against any outside
intruders at the time we are finished the island will be a
giant fortress these defenses won't hold up long term but
they should last until we carry out our plan and once
accomplished we'll be that much closer to our ultimate goal
of world domination none will be able to resist our power.
Nice.
Except for me, because of my thick thighs.
With the power of my thighs, I shall resist you.
Whoop.
Good that I'm getting ammo, though.
Holy shit, because by God, I need ammo.
Desperately.
Nice.
Gold bar.
Money.
There's so much loot here.
I don't like that.
I do not like the fact that I am getting so much loot.
Doesn't make me feel good.
Is there anybody here?
Is there anybody in the P corner?
No one at the P corner?
Okay.
That's good to know.
No one's going to the bathroom in the caves.
Alright.
Down we go.
go this way look oh i just want to make sure i have
everything reloaded
oh wait are these soldiers operation haviere few people have
heard the name even within the highest ranks of the u.s
government and little wonder too the operation was not made
public It was conducted in secret and then buried.
The reason being it was too inhumane.
It all started back in 2002, when a small unit of U.S.
special forces was sent to infiltrate an area of South
America.
Their mission was to eradicate the drug cartels.
The whole operation took several years to prepare for it,
and only the most elite soldiers were selected to
participate.
Wait, why wasn't I selected to participate?
Leon, are you not elite enough?
I don't know if the mission was a failure or not But I do
know the fate of those elite soldiers once it was over
Apparently the entire unit was wiped out Except for the
commanding officer Major Blank And not by the cartels But by
the US Oh wait that's it That's that guy Knife guy Oh I was
This is me?
I was part of that mission It's been 20 years, I don't
remember.
It shouldn't have been difficult to extract a
single-stranded unit.
All it would have taken was a single helicopter, but for
some reason, the military didn't act.
Rumors say that a decision was the outcome of a power
struggle among the top brass.
Others say it was a directive from the former president
himself, but we may never know the truth since it was all
covered up.
But I'm certain of one thing.
The U.S.
government let those people die.
brave young people who dedicated their lives to protect
their country i want to expose oh my god he's a
whistleblower he's that guy wiki leaks i want to expose this
crime not because it's my responsibility as a reporter but
because it is my duty as a fellow american check this out on
wika leak soon um number note one the document concerns
operation habier and was written by journalist named blank
uh not wikileaks oh my god this article will never be
published blank has already been taken care of no they got
wiko
that's me i'm waiting jesus christ what
that's why wikileaks is gone coincidence phase one depart
from camp is because of risk is because of Resident Evil
that we don't have WikiLeaks anymore.
Depart from campus with the target.
Escort the cart.
Ashley grabs.
Oh, this is the abduction of the president's daughter.
Escort the target as usual until the start of phase two.
There should be three outside inside the vehicle, including
Baker.
Uh, Abe's unit will follow behind you in a separate vehicle.
Continue to drive.
Who cares about?
She's already kidnapped.
Do we really need to know this information?
We already... Whoa!
Oh, whose blood is that?
Mr. WikiLeaks?
Is that your blood?
Look alive.
Where did the crow go?
Shit!
No!
My loot!
My crow loot.
okay oh no
yeah i shot a crow why the crow because he owes me money
that's why okay we gotta sell this and then these two all
right we have enough to okay we gotta repair and then we
gotta repair this uh let's see We might as well upgrade our
right.
Oh, wait, actually We might as well upgrade our shotgun now
I have all the money for this anyway Yeah, all right, I'm
broke now I'm broke All right, nice There's another message
at the tent I missed out more lore No, think about the lore
guys Won't somebody think about the fucking lore?
This?
Oh, there it is.
Just us.
Watered by the blood.
Oh my god.
It's so nice of him to tell me to get ready for battle.
I know, like, other soldiers will think about, like, you
know, the ambush.
But I'm glad that he, like, prepped me for this.
Like, we're at Save 100!
Our milestone!
Yay!
Let's celebrate, everybody.
Congratulations on a hundred C's.
Yay!
We did it.
We fucking did it, guys.
Celebrate.
It's like for a birthday, but better because it's a hundred
birthdays.
I've been waiting for you.
I swear to God, are we going to knife again?
I repaired my knife this time.
Couldn't have done it while you dragoons.
You always had poor judgment.
Is that your blood?
Bro, I think you need a blood transfusion.
You're going to let you out of here alive.
You're even more naive than I thought.
You can't save her.
You can't save anyone.
Give it up, Krauser.
Being a lackey for these maniacs won't bring your men back.
And what the hell for?
Revenge on the government?
You think they would want that?
Revenge.
You think I'm doing all this for revenge?
Isn't that what this is all about?
Yeah, what is this about?
See, in that jungle, I had a revelation.
The most important thing in this world is pure, unadulted.
rated power.
Most Illuminados have given me that.
You know, you were always an asshole.
But at least you had some kind of code.
Some honor.
There's no honor and power and money.
Look at you now.
Enough reminiscing.
Move out and draw fire, soldier.
Damn.
Bro, he has a gun now?
Bro, what do you mean a knife fight?
Hey Yeah, why don't I just do this not like I have a choice
I just shoot him.
Okay guys, will I oh What's wrong That's what's wrong Whoa,
he's so fast
Shake me Bro
Bro he's special ops Oh, he's shedding combo means so hard
we need to go where the fuck did he go get gone bro he
fucking bro he shaped me so fucking hard bro that was scary
oh he's weak of course he is of course he's weak to the
knife all right all right I gotta get up here.
Oh, I got a beetle.
Okay, I wasn't...
I didn't mean to, but I got a beetle now.
I'm gonna sell that for money.
Oh, wait.
Where do I go?
He gave me the London treatment.
He sure did.
I guess I'll go this way.
Right?
This is where I came from.
No, this is where I go.
How do I get lost or ready?
Guys, How am I already lost?
Alright, let's see.
I'm gonna sell this speed up.
He became satisfied after stabbing you a few times.
Fights over.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Let's see.
I'm going to...
I don't know.
I have a fish.
I might as well just eat the fish.
Like, what am I gonna do with this fish anyway?
Like, this fish is just there.
Yeah, I'd rather sell it.
It's 10k.
It's an easy 10k.
Right there.
I know the beta raises my max HP, but look at...
Okay, I know you guys can't see my HP, but like...
Okay, wait.
God, I can't get out of...
I'll just let you know.
My HP is practically max.
Like...
I, like, basically have max HP, guys.
he barely made it out alive wait how's your gut don't think
that was the first thing you taught me all right nice we did
it he's turned this place into one big trap i can't fight
him on his terms what the fuck i'm scared what the fuck he
drunken baby bro
Oh, fuck, I'm sorry.
How did he know?
I thought I was short enough.
That was my bad.
I actually thought I was short enough.
I...
Ready to die, rookie.
What?
Bro, I hate this mess.
Oh, my God, bro.
I'm doing that.
Why?
Now there's bear traps!
Okay.
How?
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
Okay.
Okay, I hate this.
I hate this so fucking.
I hate this.
so fucking what almost got me you almost got me
okay alright just so close I wonder if I can like shoot here
oh no it doesn't holy fuck bro I hate I hate this guy I hate
him holy shit this guy fucking sucks man I'm no stranger to
covert tactics remember where how could I forget shit
where where where okay there all right oh shit okay there we
go oh my god
Bro, bro, I hate his love.
Bro, what the fuck is this boss fight, bro?
Oh, shit, he missed.
He missed.
Jokes on you.
I swear to God if there's a trap.
I swear to God, man.
I'm so paranoid now.
I'm actually...
I'm so fucked paranoid.
I swear to God.
I hate it Holy shit, I'm so fucking paranoid over this guy.
I hate him so much.
All right, nice Oh
The paranoia is kicking in It's fucking kicking in
Where are you I'd be dead if I kept listening to people like
you where are you?
Kicking right
Where are you?
I don't know.
Guess I'll ask when I see you.
Well, you've really gone all out for me.
There you go.
You shouldn't have.
Anything to make the pretty boy feel special.
Where is he?
I don't like it.
I don't know where he is.
Okay.
This is a mess right now.
This is a fucking mess right now.
Okay.
I slowly move up.
I shoot him so he doesn't show up anymore.
Is that it?
Oh, I did.
I did.
You fucking!
Fuck you!
My fucking...
Oh my god.
Okay, do I have more fish?
I don't have any more fish.
It's okay.
It's okay
I'm ready.
I'm fucking ready.
I'm so ready All right, we're gonna we're gonna you know
what?
I'm gonna eat this.
I don't need this.
I'm ready.
I am so ready What is shooting me?
Oh god, bro.
I'm fucking coming over here.
Oh my god.
Evade.
Boom.
Melee!
That's fucking right.
You fucker.
Evade!
That's fucking right.
I am not better.
You are a major
That's what you're That's right yes blocks blocks
Break free break free Boom boom boom oh shit invade no
Oh no Okay
No block.
Oh my god, bro.
Bro, he's so good.
Okay, block, block, block, block, block, melee, kick.
That's fucking right.
From you, I take that as a compliment.
Evade!
I swear I press control.
I swear to god I'll press control Oh my god
Space evade are you serious?
I swear Bro
I hate I hate him so much.
Why?
Oh god, bro, fuck this bro where is he we done here Krauser
I told you again and again no it seems it seems like getting
rid of his pot oh my god it's like Naruto he took off his
shirt and got stronger he took his hat off he's serious he's
releasing his limiters space too what's the difference
between you and me yeah look at you look at me i'm like the
only thing thick is my thighs
i need a bigger knife i'm loving this episode of tom and
jerry t thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
you're training What?
What does that mean?
What does- You lost it completely, Krauser.
You're crazy.
You're fucking crazy now.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Do I hurt him?
So that's your true power?
I can't tell if I hurt him!
Oh my god, you fucker.
Do I have to get out of here?
Congratulations on your newfound fate.
Oh, I got that!
I got that!
Oh, God.
Where is he?
Get me out of here.
Evade me!
I swear!
I evaded!
I swear to you!
Dude, fuck this guy!
I press control!
There is a delay!
It's not skill diff!
Alright, up I go.
I did!
There is a delayed input!
I swear!
I ping!
It's the ping!
Bro, you're two arms now?
Time for the teacher to beat you.
Oh, such confidence.
Bring it, Rookie!
Damn, right.
See?
There!
Are you ready, Rookie?
Hey babe!
Oh fuck bro!
I'm gonna shoot your fucking feet.
That's fucking right.
Oh god.
Oh god, where are you going?
Where are you going?
What?
Why?
The way you're going, why?
Yeah!
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
It turned into a freak.
Okay.
Oh god, please like to reload.
Oh, fucking hell!
I swear!
When he does this climb, I'm climbing!
I did it.
Oh!
Oh my god, no, Magnum is for the final boss.
I have the high ground.
Kick him down.
All I had to do was get high ground.
That was always the only way.
And I'll be like, no, I'm better than you.
I'm not a monster.
And then he just turns around and looks cool.
I'm not like you.
And then you turn around and look so cool.
And then he's like, rookie, you should never...
Never.
Oh, he- wait, what?
What the fuck?
Okay.
I did not expect that.
Never mind.
I wouldn't.
That you did, Major.
The honor!
That you did.
I thought this was anime.
I did.
I thought we were in anime.
After he got rid of his limiters?
Damn.
I actually fucking shanked him.
Leo ain't no Boy Scout.
Alright, nice.
Let's see.
How the fuck was I supposed to know he'd actually do it?
Jesus Christ, I used so many heals.
Fuck.
I can't believe it.
He actually killed him.
What a madman.
Mediate, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
No, I'll never be like you.
I'll never be.
President Giva.
Q credits.
Chapter end.
Alright.
This is, oh wait, no, that's not the worst.
That was not the worst accuracy I've had.
Two more chapters.
We're so close, guys.
We're almost there.
Two more chapters.
Holy fuck.
Which is...
This is a knife?
No.
This is a knife.
Alright.
I have this as my knife now.
Make your way to the summit.
This chapter is a pain?
You mean not the one where I just have to fight that fucking
major?
their defenses are no joke
that's gotta be their sanctuary oh there she is there's
Ashley Ashley alright fuck okay alright apparently this one
is worse
the last two chapters why would you tell me this I thought
no How is this knife stronger?
Is this knife stronger?
The fighting knife than my combat knife?
Is it actually?
It is?
Okay, I'm gonna sell this and then I'll sell my...
I'll sell my combat knife.
Jesus Christ, it is 147.
Holy fuck, that is a strong knife.
Okay.
I invested a lot on this knife.
will that be all then all right here we go get that up there
and then okay nice all right nice we're almost there rest in
peace knife what knife needs care every once in a while wait
what difference between life don't wait what
Wait, what?
I can do a wheel?
Oh, whoops.
That's awkward.
That's that's very awkward.
Whoops.
Oh, well.
But look at how cool my knife is now.
Guys.
My knife looks so cool, though.
Look at it.
Look at how cool my knife is.
No.
We live with our consequences.
No, we live.
We live with our choices.
We're not Baldur's gaining this.
With the mistakes we make.
Oh my god.
Oh, I literally...
What?
What was that?
Oh, is that my reinforcements?
Bro, how did you not kill this one guy?
No, you could...
I was supposed to know!
Who's that?
Oh my god.
Democracy!
Let's go!
Let's go, it's democracy time.
i owe you one nice i can loot while he does all the work
nice i'm in the open area i'm here shoot them shoot them
shoot them where is it bro i'm done i'm doing what you told
me to do where the fuck is my oh now a little bit too late
man oh my god a little too late they're still there not me
not me
Bro!
Please.
They're right there.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
Right here!
Friendly fire.
Please.
Please, they're still there.
They're literally still there.
Bro, look behind you.
Look behind you.
Oh, thank God he actually turned around.
Turn around.
Oh my God, thank you.
Thank you.
That's all I wanted.
I just wanted you to turn around.
Holy fuck.
It only took us like 20 tries.
But he did it.
He fucking did it.
I swear.
Oh, there's boxes here.
Boxes.
Money.
Okay, there is a treasure.
Okay, nice.
So much money.
Is it just money?
It is just money.
Guys, maybe I can buy back my gun.
Guys, guys, I think I can buy back my knife.
Guys, I think it's possible.
Okay, nice.
I got a red barrel.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
Let's go.
Nice.
All right, I'll wait here.
Okay, I'm gonna wait here.
Go do your thing.
You go do your thing.
You go do your thing?
You go.
Nice.
Yay!
Um, yeah, you definitely don't.
You gotta hit me or the enemy.
That's for sure.
He definitely doesn't miss, guys.
Okay, we're gonna get him right now.
Bro, what the fuck?
Who are you shooting at?
Oh, there.
Nice.
I'll just stay here.
It's alright.
Can you shoot that one guy?
Can you shoot him?
He's getting awfully close to me.
He's getting closer.
Helicopter?
Where are you?
Oh, there you are.
Thank you.
Thank you for the assistance.
See, is there anything else I'm missing here?
Alright.
Boop.
Apako.
Nice.
Looter's always good.
Okay, I can combine this now.
That was the only thing I was missing.
Alright, go do your thing.
I loot.
Go do your thing.
Oh, what is that thing?
Oh!
What
do you mean?
What the fuck?
I have to destroy the anti-aircraft?
Bro, you had one job.
It's locked.
I guess I go this way.
Wait, loot.
Don't worry, he'll be fine.
I just got loot.
How do I get in?
fuck it in all right knock knock oh shit okay I did not see
that I don't know I'm trying to fucking deal with this guy I
am trying so hard nobody appreciates me wait What the fuck?
Wait, get the arm.
Excuse me, get the arm.
Okay, maybe I shoot like this.
There we go.
Nice.
Alright.
Where are the others?
Oh, it's fine.
The legs.
There we go.
Alright, are you dead?
Yay!
No, we're not gonna use the date.
We will use everything we have on the last boss.
guys i swear oh my god it'll be so worth it guys we'll use
everything on the last boss guys
we'll just throw everything we have all our needs all our
all the flashbangs everything because I believe
wait what where's the fire from oh there he is wait no where
the fuck is the fire guy oh you're right above me so are you
alright what the fuck okay there you are I did not see you
there oh my god where's your arm where the fuck is your arm
Okay, nice.
Wouldn't it be funny if the boss is a gimmick and you
don't...
Excuse me?
What do you mean the boss is a gimmick?
What does that mean?
I'm sorry, but what does that mean?
No, there's no way.
No, you're fucking with me.
There's no way.
You have to be fucking with me.
That'd be so funny.
But we all know that's a joke.
It'd be so funny, but it's a joke, right?
Right guys?
But well, yeah, it's all like hypothetical.
It's just a hypothetical, right guys?
Yeah, what if?
What if in this hypothetical situation that doesn't exist?
That's not real.
This purely hypothetical situation.
Alright, it's this way.
What the fuck is this?
How do I...
What?
Wait, how do I...
Okay, I ran in a circle.
I ran in a circle.
Alright.
We go back up.
Alright, here we go.
How the fuck do I go get there?
Go go Leon.
How?
Climb the tower?
Where?
Oh, this?
I climbed this tower?
Oh my god.
I was so confused.
Where the fuck did you come from?
Boom.
Okay, we're fine.
And then we're going to get rid of you real fast.
And then he is not going to shoot that rocket, right?
Nice.
Wait, it didn't even hit him.
Did this man just take a rocket?
Bro, this is not fair.
How can he...
Oh, God.
Tank the rocket.
Shoot the rocket.
Yeah!
That's how you game.
And he's still alive.
Alright, where is this guy?
Whoop.
Why?
I'm just gonna shoot you in the crash.
Fuck this.
I can't.
I do not have the patience to headshot you.
There you go.
Wait, where did he go?
Wait, he just... Okay, nice.
Crit.
Crit!
Let's go.
Up we go!
Anybody here?
Oh, machine gun.
Alright, so I need shotgun.
Not shotgun.
Handgun ammo.
Nice.
Can you see this?
Is that it?
Am I doing anything?
Yeah!
That's so hard to tell him.
I was actually doing anything.
Ow!
It's fine.
I don't really...
Like, what are you gonna do?
There's so...
It's such a long way to get to me.
Like, they have to walk so long.
So far.
I'm just gonna drop down.
Maybe if I just beam this guy down.
Alright.
Nice.
Drop down.
Nope.
Let me drop down here.
Nice.
Reload.
Hello?
Oh, nice.
More loot.
Yay!
Yippee!
Holy shit.
Get that door open.
This is like an action game now.
Wow!
What the fuck?
I swear.
This is just Call of Duty.
We're Call of Duty now.
The only issue is that I'm playing Call of Duty with a
handgun.
That's the only issue.
Where did you come from?
Holy fuck!
Okay, bro, fuck this.
Bro, why are you running?
Where did they come from?
Where did all of them come from?
Okay, how strong is this?
This knife is actually pretty strong.
Like, kick!
Nice.
Oh, shit!
Alright, nice.
Oh, God.
Where is he coming from?
Where is it?
Where does it go?
There we go.
Holy fuck.
Give me a sec.
I need a reload.
Who shot me?
What?
Oh my god.
There we go.
Alright.
No, no, no, no, no.
There we go.
Nice.
What the fuck?
Oh, it's the parasite.
Fuck this.
I don't care.
There you are.
Shoot you in the leg.
Is he still alive?
How are you still alive?
Where?
How?
Oh, God.
Please!
Spawning!
I don't have enough ammo!
How did you dodge all of that?
Oh, my God.
The tankiest fucking snake.
out there that's actually crazy just leave I can't they just
look at me they look so delicious you ever just look at
people and was like I can shoot that
oh my god now I know why now I know why people hate this
level now I know now I fucking know this level is actually
insane this level is so tilting you're serious really okay
all right we're just getting rid of you all right let's see
lose thank you thank god thank fucking god all right door
i'm trying there's so many people there's so many people oh
my god please i'm bringing the big guns now get closer there
you go he has to like super die right is he super dead yet
nice okay they're super dead are you fucking kidding me i
literally i swear to god i literally just got down are you
fucking kidding me bro are you super No way!
No way.
No fucking way.
This is it.
Fuck this.
Supernade.
I-
Okay, I messed up supernade.
I- Guys, I might have messed up with supernade.
guys it was made a little oopsie just a little oopsie there
look i could it said it was super the nade was bigger than
the normal nade i wasn't used to the fucking i was not guys
you don't understand i was not used to the fucking weight of
the super name.
I was throwing mini-nades this entire time.
You don't understand.
They're different weights.
Okay, here we go.
Holy fuck, I made it.
Oh my god, I'm finally inside.
I'm finally inside.
Oh my fucking I'm not inside
Oh Oh oh I thought it was still a cutscene I don't know I
thought he wanted to do something
Bro I'm not getting on that helicopter I'm so fucking dead
yeah There's no way Yeah this man's dead dead Goodbye!
Oh, you're training!
Oh no, he's training!
Mr. Frost, we get down!
Cal, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Strikes again.
The freedom!
No, Mike!
Adam Sandler.
Oh god, now it's bug time.
I'll make sure you're the next to go, Settler.
Oh, fuck this.
Fuck this.
I can't.
I can't deal with this right now.
Alright, here we go.
Oh my god.
Pro, my HP is so fucked right now.
My HP.
Alright.
We gotta heal.
We're back.
maxed out now.
We're mega maxed.
Oh, hey.
Wait.
Nice.
Holy shit.
We gotta grab the medallions.
Alright, where are all these medallions?
Is it worth it?
God, is it even worth it?
We've already maxed out our HP We don't have to worry about
that anymore Where the fuck is that?
Where is that medallion?
Is it a medallion down there?
Okay There's like a medallion here somewhere Medallion?
Medallion?
am i looking at it where is it oh my dude i don't care
enough i don't guys i am like this close to not giving a
fuck about this medallion i'm so close it's like i'm like
right there right now guys we did not we are not close to
100 guys.
There's no fucking way.
Is there a medallion here?
Oh wait, there's treasure.
Yeah!
Okay, medallion is somewhere here.
I can feel it.
I feel it.
I feel the medallion.
The bones of our brethren rest in all nations.
The blood of our brethren provide all food.
We die only to be rebuked.
born we live on through eternity we reign absolute all right
what's this oh my god this historical item that i'm gonna
sell hey has to be here somewhere where is it where am i
looking at where where the is it
It belongs in the museum.
Oh my god, there it is.
We got one.
We need two more.
Just two more.
Alright guys, use your eyes.
This is your time to shine.
It's time to use your eyes.
Oh there.
I used my eyes.
Last one.
Last one is all the way back.
back there.
Nice to be.
There should be no other way.
Guys, it's time!
Open your eyes!
Nice.
I knew.
I knew I could trust all you guys to open your eyes.
Bam!
I did it.
I looked up.
What the?
No.
I fucking knew it
I fucking knew it I was like I knew it I fucking knew it I
was like body bag no there's no way there's a random fucking
pile of body bags here okay I'm just swinging around As if
there's nothing at all It's like there's wearing nothing at
all Alright I felt it Oh guys I felt it The repairs were
complete Were completed without issue Since the facility was
previously used for confinement, the work required to
reinforce the airtight ceiling was minimal.
As long as we don't run into any issues with the cooling
system test, we plan to bring in all the remaining specimens
from Facility 1.
All specimens were successfully transferred.
However, we experienced a slight hiccup during the transfer
as one of them became violent.
Luckily, the number of casualties was less than anticipated.
Please be extra careful when dealing with them.
They received reports that they are beginning to acquire a
tolerance to the low temperature.
Oh my god.
Bro, why?
Do you really need more?
Do you really need to fuck me over even more?
Oh no.
Where is it?
Where is that one?
There you are.
I can see you.
I see you.
I see you Okay Oh Wait what Oh no It's the Iron Maiden
bullshit Okay Yeah do this again What the fuck Okay Do you
know more?
Wait was there Wait oh my god this was the way to go oh my
god no
oh i thought this was not the way to go
i legitimately thought i went the like the the detour just
want to be sure you know just want to be sure i can't trust
anybody anymore Oh my god, there's still the snake?
There's still like, where did he go?
Where did the snake go?
Guys, I lost the snake.
I lost the snake.
He just disappeared.
Where did he go?
Bro, he slithered out.
He's just gone.
actually just gone like there you go nice
there he was he thought he thought he could fuck me over
here it's not through here I guess it's through here then oh
my god I see you I
see you over there I I hate that noise.
I think that's the worst part.
Is this noise?
Really?
Okay.
Oops.
There we go.
I think that's what I don't like.
Like, ah!
Like, the body bag?
Are you fucking...
Okay.
He bent his head.
Oh!
Okay.
That was unfortunate.
There's no way that hits me.
Yeah, there's no way.
Okay.
I'll make sure.
God, bro!
God, I'm so anxious.
Just listening to that.
The fionn, fion, fionn, fion.
It just makes me so fucking anxious.
Fionn, fionn, fionn.
It is.
It's so annoying and I'm like just filled with anxiety just
listening to the body bags.
Nice.
Oh, fucking hell.
Fuck that room.
The sound of chains.
oh my god here you go here's your fucking spinelas grab the
staff all right nice and then i'll sell the viper too i
don't need that do i have machine gun yeah i do i knew i had
some i always have like sub machine gun ammo for some reason
i have an egg what do i do with it i guess i can eat the egg
You know, you know, no, I will kill them.
I don't care.
I will kill them no matter what.
Oh, I have enough money.
We'll upgrade this.
And then...
I might as well.
Yeah.
I fully upgrade my shotgun.
Okay.
And then, I guess after that...
We'll save it a little bit.
Oh, my God.
Bam.
Here we go!
I'm ready!
Reload.
Hello.
I swear to God if there's more body bags.
I swear to fucking God.
Where I cannot deal with this.
I am not.
Ashley, please.
Are you... Where?
Oh.
Oh, bug!
Okay, bug is fine.
I'm fine.
Keep coming.
It's fine.
Bug is fine.
Bug, I don't care as much.
It's really like...
Okay.
What?
Man, I was gonna say, that's fucked up.
Okay.
There you go.
Just gonna make sure I get rid of all of you guys first.
And also that mine.
There you go.
I don't know?
What?
What do I not know?
What, guys?
What do you mean?
She doesn't know.
God damn it.
Don't tell it.
What do you... what?
I don't like this.
I don't like how you're like she doesn't know.
I don't like this at all.
I don't like what that implies.
Why wouldn't I know?
Why wouldn't I know, chat?
This is terrible.
This is a very terrible.
I hate this so much.
Oh no, where the fuck is the rocket launcher man?
Oh, I got the fish at least.
I got fish.
It's not important.
What do you mean?
I feel like it's very important.
Give me a break already.
I feel like it's so important.
How?
Bro, I can't.
Oh my god, that's where you were.
Oh, my arm.
It does not look so well.
I don't feel fine.
I do not feel fine.
I do not feel fine at all.
Let's see.
I'm just going to make sure there's no bugs here.
I mean, eventually...
You know what?
Fuck it.
I can't.
I can't care enough.
Look at all these iron gun ammo.
All will be revealed!
Oh, guys.
But what if I want you to reveal it now?
Is that not a fucking beeper?
I swear to fucking die.
Alright.
Okay, it's time.
Grenade.
Oop.
Ow!
Alright, here we go.
it's okay we're fine we used our grenades we're using our
grenades that's good that's so good
next oh my god please i have so much ammo
all right nice all right i got the head we got the okay
please give me more nice give me a break already it's fine
we're fine we're doing it we're surviving stop told you
we're survivors now we can go in here holy shit there's so
many enemies I feel like I should I've been stealthing this
entire time!
Holy fuck.
If this was...
If this was stealth, I would not have to worry about all
these fucking people.
Get out.
Get outta here.
Oh my god.
Get the fuck outta here.
Oh, if only we had Mike!
Where's Mike?
I miss Mike.
I miss him so much.
Mike would have fucking saved me.
What the fuck?
Nice.
There.
Yeah, my fucking sniper is so tanky.
Shit, I like two shot this man.
This.
Whoa!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, God.
Oh, okay.
That's fine.
Oh, this is not fine.
This is not fine.
Where did you come from?
Jesus Christ.
Oh, God.
Oh, that's...
This is not good!
Okay.
Alright, we're good.
We're okay.
Oh, we're okay.
We lived.
We're okay.
We are alive.
Lure.
Give me all the loot.
Holy shit.
Thank you.
Thank you for all the ammo.
I'm so poor Thank God Not panicking I'm not panicking I am
very calm Turn off I'm so fucking calm right now Okay, we
gotta go this way Down I go Down I go We're so calm We need
more fucking shotgun ammo We're so fucking calm.
Oh, we made it here.
We made it so far.
Wait, what?
Why?
Why did I just press this?
What?
Okay.
I'm so calm.
I am So very calm Oh my god My HP was not very calm My HP
was like Not calm at all Okay let's see let's go Hello Oh
man Why does that look like that Why does it look like that
Oh come on Go after Ashley Aww Aww but what if i don't adam
adam and eve
ah ah ashley ah
ashley ashley welcome
my child oh adam sadly i simply wish to share this gift with
his many as possible a humble wish don't you think you see
we are all connected through the holy body and now your
flesh and bones your very thoughts are already one with us
why do you reject serenity bro what if i just like to keep
Ashley, can I just leave?
Like she did.
Suther?
Oh.
Ah, yes.
The time has come.
Globy's lamb to join our covenant.
Oh, blessings unto him and the sweet mercy they bring.
And salt calls and let it be done.
Oh, shit.
Oh, I'm okay.
This is by the scratch.
Oh, my Ada, you could have done this earlier, Ada.
Oh, no.
Why am I carrying her?
Ashley, wake up.
Ashley, please, please wake up, Ashley!
Ashley, no, no, Ashley, Ashley, no!
Ashley, wake up, wake up, Ashley, please, please, Ashley.
Ashley, please.
Ashley, please, you're so heavy!
Oh no.
No.
What is this?
Still you resist, child.
Huh?
What do I do?
Go towards the light.
Just go towards the light.
Just go towards the light!
Go, Leah!
Go faster!
God damn it!
Leah, please!
She's not that heavy!
She's like a fucking teenager!
All right, yeah, I don't fucking know.
Oh, just go faster.
Leon, please!
You're tired?
You were never tired when you were fucking running for 20
years.
Oh my god, I have a one key.
Actually too heavy.
Oh, holy shit.
Get in there, Ashley.
You're home.
It has to be different.
Get in there.
Sit in the chair.
Sit in the fucking chair.
Like I told you, I'm gonna get you home safe.
Get in the robot, Ashley.
Don't worry, it's not gonna hurt.
we have no morphine to help you quit to help you not feel
pain
close your eyes ashley it won't it's only gonna hurt a
little bit we're gonna shoot the bus oh god
bro that's like so close to her heart bro
We did it!
Yay!
You're okay.
The end.
And thus Leon could never continue the bloodline.
Oh my god.
That level fucking sucked.
That level was fucking terrible.
That had to be the worst chapter.
That actually was the worst chapter.
Ashley I thought you were gonna die Okay
Not the bloodline You did this Yeah Yeah I did this Bro she
healed up so fast I like how Leon gets to have the procedure
while he's unconscious He had the privilege of being
unconscious For this entire thing
Hey We're a team, right?
Keep this up.
I'll be out of a job.
Oh, yeah.
How the fuck did Ashley put him on the chair?
Bro, what the fuck, Ashley?
We're fucking jacked.
There are two ways to eradicate Les Plagueis.
Antigen injection and surgery.
If the parasite is not hatched yet, it can be treated by
administrating antigen directly into the body.
Once it is hatched, however, there's not much that can be
done With surgery, the plaque can be targeted and killed
Using a certain wavelength of radiation That is That was a
lot of radiation Near the fucking heart This is not without
its risk Oh shit yeah It's a parasite has attached It's up
to the host's nervous system The host will experience
excruciating pain And there is no effective anesthesia For
this kind of procedure Surgical removal carries considerable
risk even before the parasite is fully developed.
Once fully grown, however, if it is too late, removing the
parasite will kill the host.
But considering what will happen to them, death may be a
mercy.
This was Luis.
Yeah, we're alive.
Thank you, Luis.
He's alive too, by the way.
Oh, there is.
Umbrella.
Oh, there's Luis!
There he is!
Bro.
i bet the guy that opened that umbrella is fucking dead all
right what's this do we not be fooled into thinking that les
plagues are merely tools for creating powerful bio weapons
the true value lies in their ability to control no matter
how hostile a subject a single injection can turn anyone
into a faithful servant who needs spies when you turn
yesterday's enemy into today's ally controlling just one
insider can bring an entire organization an entire country
to its knees mass production of the superior species has
made this possible we have empowered sadler it is clear what
he intends to do next can you imagine if sadler had that
much control six billion loyal servants at his sole command
there will be no opposition no war that's not bad no war
maybe for the first time in human yeah see in human history
and the others have oppressed the people of this island for
generations i know how he treats them there's no way to live
and because of that i won't let it happen yeah but like not
the most uncomfortable places but like if it's like one
person you know like one like you you wouldn't care when you
get control even booted up oh god you know how old this pc
is What the fuck?
Look how thick that PC is.
Look how thick it is.
This sample, which I've come to call the amber, was just
sitting in the storeroom collecting dust.
We used to have ample specimens for experimentation in the
past, so it makes sense that this one was overlooked.
In fact, the only reason I brought it back in my lab was
because of its peculiar shape.
After a basic analysis, I've changed my mind.
The amber possesses a very unique quality.
say it contains the same organ found in a dominant species
which we've only seen in sadler himself when fully developed
the amber may rev may rival or perhaps even surpass sadler's
power oh this is the one this was the one that was in in
ashley unfortunately the amber was confiscated by sadler
before i can make any further progress in my research he may
be on to me i need to get my hands on that sample again and
escape in order to continue my research elsewhere it's the
only way to counter Sadler.
Of course, I don't think I can trust this outside group
either.
But I've already come this far.
Hopefully I can sweet talk my way out of this one too.
I'll have to for the world's sake.
Jesus Christ!
Lewis, keep all your notes in one area!
Lewis, why are your notes fucking spread to like four PCs?
Please!
All of Lewis's notes are scattered everywhere.
Keep it in one PC, Lewis!
Alright, here we go.
I like this.
Get up.
The chink office.
Alright.
healthier I'll be back do not get kidnapped I swear to
fucking God I swear to God do not get kidnapped while I grab
this there you go yeah go up yeah it was 30 seconds last
time I just don't trust her I don't trust her at all Oh,
I'm so fine.
I'm so okay.
Just a little radiation in my heart.
That's okay.
Doesn't hurt nobody.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, no.
Why do I have to bring up my rifle?
Why?
This is where you died.
You think she's all right?
Oh, I'm sure she's fine She's not the type to roll over that
easy Yeah, don't worry The effects will show up in like 10
to 15 years And maybe by then we'll find a cure Right,
Ashley?
Whoa
Okay I just want to make sure How do I get over there?
Yeah?
Oh, sorry, yellow paint.
I see the yellow paint now.
What cure?
I don't know.
What do you guys think is going to happen when you have all
that radiation in your heart, chat?
Do I really need that treasure?
Do I care enough?
Do I really care enough about that fucking treasure, chat?
Fine.
Super heart?
That's how you get superpowers.
You don't understand.
That's how superpowers work.
Wait, which one was it?
Is it...
Okay, it's this.
This is what I'm looking at.
There we go.
Yeah, what the fuck?
I swear I shot that.
Okay.
That superheroes taught us.
Please do not...
Guys, I don't think that's what's gonna happen.
Praise be to the holy insect.
Lord Kurosus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Superpowers.
How else do you explain Chris Redfield's ability to punch
boulders?
Women promise paradise on earth.
Man, women, or child.
His love does not discriminate.
Beast, fish, or bird, or creature, all creatures shall be
equally blessed.
Praise be to the holy insects.
We are the humble servants of God.
any mountain his omnipotence will um will cross any ocean
the light of heaven dwells in all things let our bodies be
seated praise be to the holy insects we are the flock and
the shepherd guides us our prayers will be sung all over the
world and they will be heard by all at last we shall exceed
in the stars good time yay Oh my god, Adam Sandler.
Big fan.
I love you and Hansel and Gretel.
I actually watched that movie.
I actually watched it.
I watched that twin movie from Adam Sandler.
No way.
Unfortunately, yes.
Unfortunately, yes way.
I have watched a lot of really bad movies.
And I mean a lot of bad movies.
Why?
Look, I watched...
I paid for movie tickets to movies that I should not have
paid for.
Because, like, back in those days, you would see the
trailers on TV.
and stuff and all your thinking was like it can't be that
bad whoa and then like you and your parents would just be
like the one of the 10 people at the theater watching that
movie there was this movie with god what was it like this
like alien race controlling like a but like controlling this
robot person it was so bad i it was so bad i don't remember
what that movie was called but all i remember was we were
one out of like 10 like five people in the theater it all
right i think we can upgrade durability armor and then we
should be good yeah the eddie murphy one before going this
way be ashamed to live the rest of you oh is this the last
wait am i gonna find the merchant again sell all of your
gems oh okay is this the last time i see the merchant is it
the last door no okay i'm just gonna i'm gonna sell
everything then i'm selling everything i'm gonna do it
I'm gonna do it.
I did it.
Alright, let's see.
I still... Oh, wait, I do have it.
Alright, might as well.
I might as well max it up.
Okay, I maxed it up.
And then...
I might as well get the...
I don't really care about the gun and, like, this gun.
I might as well upgrade this.
Animal capacity.
I don't have that much ammo.
So I'll just... I'll just do ammo capacity.
Boop!
There we go.
I mean, I could do one.
Yeah.
Alright.
Right enough.
Reload speed.
Radar fire.
Might as well.
Alright, that's good.
Alright, let's figure out the inventory.
Situation.
Okay.
Nice.
I might as well use my spinners too.
Alright, what do I need?
Uh, 23.
Uh, gunpowder.
I guess I could get the chip.
Oh my god.
These are...
Oh my god, I could have...
There's some things money can't buy.
I could have bought the challenge.
oh my god god fucking damn it how do i keep doing this to
myself
oh it's fine we don't reload anything we live we live with
our bad decisions chat we have to live with our bad
decisions in life.
Oh my god, I'm so stupid.
I'm so stupid.
Look where?
Look what?
What am I looking at?
What?
Oh, this!
I was like, who, where?
Okay.
Is that, I'm like, huh?
All right, before we're going to look at her.
And then we use the bathroom.
Okay, I'll be right back.
Last bathroom break.
I'll be right back.
All right, Heda.
I'm coming for you.
I'm going to save you, Heda.
let's go let's go stay here oh thank god oh thank god yes
stay here
that makes me feel a lot better please stay there
oh that is very
bro you're so lucky she did not land on her head.
You're so fucking lucky.
Bro, that's fucking meta.
That gotta hurt.
Bro, she's okay.
She's in heels, but she's okay.
Shoot the head.
Stop shooting the arm.
You're like five feet.
Oh, shit.
shaken
oh oh to become what
oh she bro
oh fuck those are a lot of eyes this is it this is it this
is not it
this might not be it guys let me go let me go okay wait wait
wait i got it guys this is it wait why is your eyes not open
oh i go down go down leon why
am i why am i using my pistol oh god oh god run oh but what
if what if i get loot oh i can stab your eyes stab his eye
stab his eye
oh run run run run run run no
this is it where's my nades where is my big name where is he
oh god oh god oh god oh the babies oh where is he jumping to
i'm so lost okay where why am i using my pistol i am so
confused let's throw let's throw no i'm
trying to throw everything i'm trying to throw everything
right now wait i have a magnum guys oh my god no no
Go!
Bro!
Oh, please!
Oh, God.
Okay, this is it.
Oh, no.
This is it.
Let me out.
Oh, thank God!
phase two this has to be phase two
there's no way there's no way there's a phase two there's no
way there's no way i didn't get an achievement
i'm getting sick of your shit
there's always a phase two there's always a phase two how
What do I do?
Finally, I looked at suits you, Sadler.
A monster in and out.
Still.
I need to cut the stage short.
It's not me.
Yeah.
It's you.
Oh, God.
Hey, Vade, Vade.
Yes!
Rocket launcher!
Where is it?
Don't miss.
It was possible.
Oh, fuck.
One last shank for the ride.
Goodbye, Adam Sandler.
Your Netflix deals are over.
I didn't miss all those eggs.
Trade me for this moment.
Hello, Ada.
God,
I hate her voice acting in this one.
It's just so dead inside.
Like, I guess she's supposed to be dead inside, but still.
She's like mega dead inside.
I think we both know this is where we go our separate ways.
I see
Oh Ada Better get a move on Ada What Better get a move on
Ada What can I, why can't I join you on the helicopter
Where is she going Who knows I don't understand Why Why
would she just...
Oh!
Yeah, we better move, Ashley.
Oh no.
You know, Ada, you could have just like let Ashley and I on
the fucking boat, like on the fucking helicopter.
You know?
Wait, it hurt!
Which way, which way, which way?
Okay, let's get out of here.
Which way?
Okay, we gotta go, we gotta go.
I'm reloading every fucking gun I have.
We gotta go.
Yes, we can't, Ashley.
Just keep running.
Whoa!
Don't worry.
Yeah, why the fuck did you refuse?
Fuck you!
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
Keep running.
There's nothing now their master's gone.
Move!
Ashley, I would love it if you could help out.
Thank you for watching, Ashley.
All right.
About that, Ada.
I really appreciate that.
You're gonna love this.
Wait, what?
I still have to play?
What do you mean?
I still have...
Where's my cutscene?
No cutscene for me, I guess.
Ow!
Oh, fuck.
Oh, oh, this is not good.
This is...
What?
The slowest fucking jump to that ramp.
Oh my god, I can't believe no cutscene privileges.
No cutscene privileges for me.
Whoa!
Oh god, oh shit, oh shit, oh we're dead.
Actually, this is it.
Actually, I fucked up.
Please, please tell me this is the end.
Oh god, oh this is so bad.
Actually, the boat is 1 HP.
We are one hit, guys.
We are one hit.
Woo!
Oh, crap!
We were
1 HP.
I'm not sure that was insane.
We did it.
Yeah.
Finally got my cutscene.
I did it.
Mission accomplished, right?
Mission accomplished.
When you're home safe.
Thank you for saving me.
Oh.
You know, I could put in a word with my dad.
Bro, nepotism?
I can assign to my detail if you're interested.
Bro.
you don't need me you proved you could handle yourself
actually if you could use a lesson in knife safety can't
chris won't let me i got it i got a hook up with claire i
can't actually
bro bro i'm scared of chris man
connor one roost to connor one do you read me come in i said
come in is this thing even on leon leon are you and ashley
all right bro answer this is bro if i don't answer she's
gonna think i killed the president's daughter like he's
gonna be like oh no the point i'm sorry mr president your
daughter's dead leon did not answer i can't believe that
he's coasting his work Man, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Congrats on clearing Resident Evil 4.
8 out of 10 out of 10.
So she opens her mouth.
Can't wait to hear.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Don't worry, guys.
We're totally coming back for part 4.
Don't worry.
Zoderman, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I missed a scene in the OG when she... Oh, wait.
Does she actually do this?
Like, no one kicks her off in just.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Redfield.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yes, the bloodline will continue.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
I'm so happy to beat Resident Evil 4 chat.
I'm so fucking happy.
We did it, everybody.
I'm so tired.
What a journey.
What a fucking journey.
Oh my god.
Almost seven hours today.
I'm definitely going to take it to mom.
Definitely going to be more chill.
What's this?
Oh, that's the cult.
That's the cult.
Is there after credit scene chat?
Are you actually going to do of course not.
Guys, there's always been a line for DLC.
Guys, I'm already I'm fucking tired.
I'm tired.
uh lord kurosus thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you considering in resident evil 5 chris redfield can
backhand zombie so hard their heads detonate due to his
biceps being the size of tree trunks yeah i'm afraid of him
too thank you for the super chat thank you thank you yeah
dlc gets in the line that's to be in the line oh after
credits is that ada Oh, that's the amber.
Callan, thank you for the time.
Get the ships.
Thank you.
Patch me through.
Mike, too.
I've obtained the amber.
Is that Wesker?
Hey, Wesker.
Just one question.
What are you planning to do with this?
Do not pay you to ask questions.
Whoa!
All you need to know is a new dawn is breaking.
Damn.
You let him talk to you like that, Ada?
May live.
And expediting that change.
Let's go.
We're talking millions of casualties.
Billions.
How ambitious.
Oh.
We're changing.
course now oh he's like bro i watch my twins dead that's
fine oh that's them there's leon and ashley also have they
eaten at all oh
we did it oh my god we fucking did it oh d dragon think of
the super chat thank you thank you i'm sorry Chris but an OG
canon Leon and Ada have one have gotten jiggy with it and at
one point between kitties thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you ggs everyone ggs we fucking did it we fucking
beat Resident Evil 4 I'm so happy productions thank you for
super chat thank you thank you I didn't know now I'm here
from JJK wasn't Resident Evil 4 many thank you but super
chat thank you so easy to aid out same thank you the super
chat thank you thank you oh my god is there another after
after credit scene guys is there i just i just need a note
is there another after after credit scene i can't trust any
games anymore everyone always adds an after credit scene to
everything it's like there's always after credit scenes for
every fucking like after I fucking knew it.
The after after credit scene.
The Marvel syndrome.
That's us.
We're safe.
Good work.
B.
Excuse me?
I had an 80 plus percent fucking 14 hour.
I had an 80 percent accuracy rate average.
I can't believe it.
Well, I got sunglasses, though.
Look, 80%.
Cole, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Here, catch.
Thank you, Cole.
I can't.
Too many saves.
Are you serious?
Does that actually affect your...
What?
Look, you can't be too careful with saving.
You can't be too careful.
I grew up with saving.
all the time.
We're always saving our games.
No matter where we are at.
We loot one thing, we save the game.
We take one damage, we save the game.
Oh my god.
We did it.
I'm so happy.
We fucking did it.
Our second game completed.
my game's not closing oh i was like i was like why isn't my
game closing
oh my god i'm so tired i'm so tired i bet you guys are
really tired too but i had such a fun time i had a really
fun time beating this game chat i can't believe we did it
dying right now watching a seven like almost seven hours of
this but we fucking did it chat we fucking we made it that's
all that matters we fucking made it to the end thank you
everybody the next game series we're gonna uh we're gonna
start next is dead rising we're gonna start dead rising uh
next week because um it's also a game i've been really
wanting to play for a very time and uh this i can actually
finally play it and i'm so excited johnny thank you welcome
to the tomato farm welcome welcome yes the first one i want
to be a journalist i want yes the first one i've always
wanted to be a journalist so i'm gonna play dead rising uh
yeah thank you for the super chat thank you thank you i'm a
speedrunner for this game and i got an aim i so three hours
a completion one time what the fuck then how do you get like
an a modest like like i mean like how like why is it so hard
to get like a good grade uh yeah thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you it was really fun not not scary
congrats dokey okay the regenerator probably was so fucked
up that shit that one was fucked up i did not like that i
did not i i did not like the regenerators at all that was so
fucked up man that was so messed up oh my god oh i think the
worst part was that i have to like i the body bags i hear
the body so much because even though I know there was no
regenerators the fucking sound of it was like bring bring
bring bring bring bring bring bring bring bring bring bring
bring bring bring bring bumping I've been like listening to
that song non-stop for like last two days uh T thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you here's for you to spend
it at the mall next week thank you the super chat thank you
thank you I don't know like I know like I'm like one month
late which is like me with every fucking anime out there i'm
like way too late for the trend uh bling bam bang born but
like that song is so fucking addicting that's such a sick
hook anyway guys i am gonna call it here i hope you guys had
a great time watching um i had a great time streaming this
for you guys um as always everybody stay hydrated posture
check get up and move around to get that blood flowing and
if you stay up for me head to bed because you this deserve
it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.